Jetzt wird nichts mehr getroppt, ne?
Jetzt ist angeblich, jetzt ist angeblich
alles gut. Jetzt ist angeblich,
jetzt wird nichts mehr getroppt
und in der Vorschau sieht es bei mir jetzt auch gut aus.
Ist besser?
Guckt mal, ob
jetzt bei euch besser ist. Alter, ich hab jetzt wieder nur
33 FPS ingame.
WTF? Alter!
Sledgehammer,
was habt ihr denn da gemacht?
Ich hab wieder, jetzt muss ich das Game
nochmal beenden, weil ich wieder nur 33 FPS
hab. Irgendwas stimmt
mit dem Game nicht.
Ja, ich weiß, dass Black Screen ist, weil ich wieder nur
33 FPS ingame hab.
Also, ich kann alles streamen,
aber Call of Duty
darf ich wohl nicht streamen. Das ist zu
advanced.
Das Game ist echt
einziger Bug, wie es aussieht.
Starten wir es nochmal neu.
Ja.
Zurück zu Advanced Warfare.
Ich hab mir übrigens ein neues Streaming
Setup ausgedacht.
Mit meinem zweiten Rechner jetzt.
Ähm, Graphics.
Das Foff-Reset.
Also, der PC-Port
ist Bullshit, ey.
Ist doch der Witz.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Was ist das hier?
Wie ist das Game denn? Ich kann ehrlich gesagt
noch relativ wenig zu dem Game sagen.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass der PC-Port einfach
scheiße ist.
Das Foff-Reset hat sich immer wieder.
Das Game ruckelt nach 3-4 Runden einfach
bis zu 32-33 FPS runter.
Also, lächerlich.
Wirkt total lächerlich.
So, mal gucken, wie es jetzt läuft.
Hättest du mal
ihn neu gekauft.
Autsch. Und vom Gameplay.
Ja, das Gameplay fand ich ja in der Beta schon ganz gut.
Bloß, dass in der Beta halt die ganze
Hacker-Cheater-Kacke das total versaut hat.
Die Maps finde ich sehr
merkwürdig. Also, teilweise finde ich die Maps gut.
Die hier zum Beispiel.
Die macht einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Falls es die ist mit den Häusern.
Nicht, dass ich das jetzt verwechsle.
Also, mit dieser Innenstadt.
Ja, genau. Die finde ich
beispielsweise ganz gut. Da gibt es so eine offene
Schneemap. Die ist totaler Kack.
Ich hatte ja
tatsächlich irgendwie so ein bisschen die Motivation
wieder mal, wenn Call of Duty zu
spielen, auch mal ein bisschen länger. Um mir das
anzugucken alles. Und
auch halt mal in das Game ordentlich wieder
reinzukommen. Das Problem ist, wenn das
so beschissen läuft.
Habe ich da eigentlich kaum Bock drauf.
Guck.
Jetzt habe ich wieder 150 FPS, 170 FPS,
200 FPS, 215 FPS.
Alles gut. Und nach zwei, drei
Runden habe ich wieder 30.
Das war übrigens nicht die Route, die ich laufen wollte.
Suche Gegner.
Oh, Mann.
Oh, veraimt. Übelst veraimt.
Und zu wenig Leben gehabt.
Hast du versucht, deine Grafikkarte wieder außen einzuschalten?
Ist klar.
Lul 3D.
Und Sniper nerven mich.
Sniper...
Sniper nerven mich übel.
Noch nicht komplett...
Moment, der Typ ist unter mir.
Sniper.
Why?
But why? Warum?
Lass Animation von Windows
deaktivieren.
Ich bin immer
gefühlt sofort tot.
Echt mal Zeit, dass ich den Kram wieder ein bisschen
öfter spiele.
Instant tot. Auch gut.
Verstehe das nicht.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich...
was ich anders machen sollte, da.
Kommt noch was zu Overwatch, ja?
Sobald man den Rank-Modus spielen kann.
Wieder spielen kann.
Fuck, fuck, was ist Mehle?
Oh, ohohoho.
Ahem, die F...
Ich hab... muss erst mal die Taste suchen für Nahkampf, äh...
Oh, mein Aim.
Mein Aim ist so schlecht.
Ich hab's...
Ich muss echt wieder mehr...
spielen, einfach, dass ich wieder ordentlich treffe.
Das ist... das ist nicht mal ein A-Aim.
Das ist Brexit-Aim.
Äh.
What?
Was für ein Rang?
Äh.
Ich hab letzte Seasons 10 Placement-Matches gemacht, das war's.
Was hatte ich denn?
Keine Ahnung.
Äh.
Kurz vor Grandmaster irgendwo, glaub ich, ne?
Irgendwie 3900 nach Placements oder sowas.
necessarily
R.
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Ich...
pack's nicht, äh...
Ich muss... ich muss grade nochmal raus.
Ich muss grad nochmal raus.
Irgendwas stimmt an den Settings doch nicht.
Und die Maus ruckelt wieder.
Wobei ich hatte bei Overwatch nie Probleme irgendwie was zu treffen.
Entweder liegt das wirklich daran, dass ich einfach viel zu wenig gespielt habe,
oder dass ich Call of Duty Steuerung nicht gewohnt bin.
Aber vielleicht mal ein Ticken noch höher?
Now if you wait, now the NA
ain't overrated.
Ich meine, in der Beta ging's ja auch, ne?
War ein paar richtig coole
Gameplays dabei.
Stream doch mal wieder MW2.
Ich hab MW2 auf dem PC gar nicht.
Ähm, gibt's denn,
gibt's denn für MW2
dieses, dieses, ähm,
wie hieß das denn?
Alternative Net oder so?
Gibt's das noch? Alter IW-Net
und, ähm, die, die, die ganzen Dinger?
Hast du mal Dota
gespielt? Nein.
Ja, hab ich. Das, das, das Warcraft
3 Dota. Aber nicht Dota 2.
Äh, und CS
ist nicht meins. Overwatch ist eigentlich
genau mein Game.
Overwatch ist eines der, der
geilsten Games, die in den letzten Jahren
rausgekommen sind. Das Problem ist, dass das
Ranking-System einfach, das,
so als wüsste Blizzard nicht,
soll es jetzt einfach
casual sein oder soll es
eSport-mäßig sein? So als ist sie, als
versuchen,
sie irgendwie den Spagat und kriegen sie es für beide
Richtungen nicht richtig hin.
Na, aber auf Steam kannst du MW2
bestimmt nicht spielen. Das ist wahrscheinlich noch mehr
gehackt und kaputt.
Ja, aber LOL und Dota
und CS, na ja, CS hat auch
so ein kleines Cheater-Problem. Die kriegen
das halt mit dem Ranking-System auch hin.
Overwatch kriegt das nicht gebacken.
Enemy, beiße. Beiße was?
Ich hab keine Granate.
Ich muss weg. Ah,
scheiße.
Mopas sind, ehrlich gesagt,
nicht so meins.
Wir müssen noch ins Flaschgegner kommen.
Oh, das ist der
MP40?
Aber weggesprayt.
Ich treff nix.
Ich treffe nix, ey.
So deprimierend.
Taugt das Spiel was?
Vom Gameplay her ganz okay,
aber auf dem PC halt
ziemlich verbuggt.
So mit
Rumgeruckeln nach zwei Runden.
Oh fuck, die Munition ist leer.
Ey, ich schließ bestimmt keinen Controller an.
Wo ist er?
Der muss doch hier um die Ecke stehen.
Ich lauf da jetzt bestimmt nicht rein.
Der steht immer noch da.
Altes Feeling von KOTA. Ich weiß
net. Ich weiß net.
Dazu müsste ich erst mal ein bisschen in das Game
reinkommen.
Wat? Fritzbomb.
Der kommt hier um die Ecke.
Die deutschen Sprüche sind so richtig
Klischee-mäßig wieder.
Wa?
Call of Duty Tod.
Typischer Call of Duty Tod.
Controlfreaks müssen auf die Maus
drauf, Leute. Ich sag's euch.
Äh.
Nicht auf den Controller.
Aimfreaks. Oder wie das Zeugs hieß.
Wo kommen denn
Gegner jetzt her? Jetzt sind sie hinter einem. Okay.
Von wo kommen denn jetzt
Gegner? Von hier?
Wat?
Wie soll man das denn
bitte kontrolliert spielen?
Zwei Gegner vorne, ein Gegner hinter, ein Gegner
rechts. Wie soll
man sich da über die Map bewegen,
dass man halbwegs safe steht?
Man kann ja eigentlich nur an der Seite
der Map lang kriechen.
Und dass man die Killcam nicht
überspringen kann, fuckt mich auch ab. Geht mir richtig
auf den Sack. Und wisst ihr, warum man die Killcam
nicht überspringen kann?
Weil sie wollen, dass man sieht, was der Gegner für eine Waffe
hatte. Vielleicht kauft man sich danach
Lootboxen. Kann man?
Mit was kann man die Killcam überspringen?
Also mit
Leertaste geht das nicht.
Mit F? Mit F? Wer kommt denn auf F?
Mit F?
Soll ich jetzt? Ja was jetzt? F oder Q?
Ich probier das jetzt das
nächste Mal.
So, hab ich hier jetzt irgendwas
freigeschaltet dafür?
Hälschen grenzen.
Na, ob das was bringt? Müssen wir mal
gucken. Warum nur TDM?
Weil ich die anderen Modi nicht gerne alleine
spiele. Max, was der
hoffst du dir vom nächsten kommt?
Ey, das hier ist jetzt erst mal 3 Tage raus.
Die müssen das hier erst mal hinkriegen.
Vom nächsten.
Würdest du mitmachen?
Ja, dann auf. Ja, lass uns, lass uns
äh, mal den neuen Modus
testen.
Spiel noch Free4All.
Das probier ich mal aus, jetzt gleich.
Das ist wenigstens nicht ganz so random.
Was erwartest du vom nächsten Mal?
Vom nächsten Battlefield.
Dass es gut wird.
Also ich erhoffte vom nächsten Battlefield,
dass ich nicht wieder gleich
Kotzanfälle bekomme vom Waffenhandling
wie im Battlefield 1.
Ich mein, was soll ich da machen jetzt?
Ich spiel jetzt echt mal ne Runde Free4All.
Das ist ne gute Idee.
Das probier mir jetzt noch mal aus.
Ich spiel jetzt ne Runde Free4All.
Die Frage ist, gibt's sowas wie leisere
Fußschritte?
Schau dir das mal nachher an.
Wo soll ich mir das nachher anschauen?
Was gibt's da zu sehen?
Ähm, ja,
genau, Battlefield 1 ist mein Lieblingsgame.
Oh Mann.
Battlefield 1, äh, ich bin
überhaupt nicht warm geworden.
Ich hab mich ja gefreut drauf.
Nachdem ich Battlefield 4 schon nicht so toll fand,
hab ich mir gedacht, und als
ich das auf diesem
Reveal-Event gewesen bin,
hab ich auch gedacht, nachdem ich die ersten
paar Sachen davon gesehen hab, man hat ja nicht wirklich viel
Gameplay gesehen, hab ich mir gedacht, hey,
da kannst du eigentlich gar nicht
so viel verkacken.
Ich mein, man hat ein
frisches Setting, man hat nicht
so viele Möglichkeiten, die Waffen
müssten eigentlich relativ, ähm,
ja,
Mechanics-basiert sein, also sprich
jetzt, äh, Singleschuss
oder, oder halt maximal
irgendwie so,
halt, ne, wie die Waffen im ersten Weltkrieg
gewesen sind. Und dann hab ich die Beta gespielt
und hab festgestellt, dass es Waffen gibt, die
genauer werden, je länger man schießt und
sowas in der Richtung. Das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Und seitdem hab ich Battlefield 1 nicht einmal
mehr angerührt.
Warum kann man eigentlich seinen Schalldämpfer
nicht schon draufmachen im...
im Spawn?
Okay, das war ein scheiß Spawnpunkt auch.
Mittendrin, ey.
Ganz vergessen, Hype wegen neuem Overwatch-
Heiler. Ähm...
Der sieht...
Ich find, das sieht ganz gut im Konzept aus.
So ne Mischung aus Zenyatta und uns...
Symmetra oder so.
Hier muss man Freefall, da muss man hören, was Sache ist.
Da ist einer.
Alter, der hat mich gesehen! Nein!
Verdammt, ich dachte, der ist weggerannt.
Wow!
Boah, was hat denn der für Attachments?
Die Waffe besteht ja nur aus Attachments.
Über die Range kann ich
nicht anstecken.
Nicht ein Treffer,
okay. Naja, ich hab vorbeigeschossen.
Das ist ein guter Modus.
Da kann man mal ein bisschen das Waffenhandling üben.
Ich hör was hinter mir.
Oder auch nicht.
Hinter mir.
Oh, NA-Aim!
Mann, kann ich heute mal wieder etwas treffen zur Abwechslung?
Ist ja schlärrecklich.
Gibt's net.
Fuck.
Oh, der Typ hat 25-2.
Ja, geh ab hier.
Noob-Hacker?
Ah!
Ich mein, nicht unbedingt, dass es
stimmen muss, zwangsläufig.
Hinter mir.
Nicht,
dass es stimmen muss.
Die Torte auf der Toilette
aufgenommen worden.
Hol... was?
Holistik? Wie oft schneidest du deine
Fingerlegel? So oft, wie es nötig ist.
Aber ich hab da so eine doofe
Angewohnheit, zumindest zwischen
Daumen und Zeigefinger.
Da bin ich ja immer so am...
Irgendwie, wenn es mir langweilig ist
und ich rumsitze und warte, dann mach ich
immer so mit dem Finger so.
Daran rum. Deswegen sind die zumindest
zwischen Daumen und Zeigefinger
irgendwie immer ziemlich kurz.
Zweiter ist die... Oh, oh, Rapid Fire!
Rapid Fire, das brauchen wir!
Jetzt geht's ab! Extended Max Rapid Fire!
Yeah!
Wie ist denn die Progression?
Additional Primary Attachments.
Oh, nice!
Also, die SCG44
quasi dann hier mit
so was wie mit Griff,
Rapid Fire, Visier und allem drauf.
Kommst du ins Discord? Ja, mache ich.
Ich spiel...
Ich spiel noch einen Free-for-all, Erx.
Einen Free-for-all will ich noch ausprobieren.
Dann komm ich in Discord.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Fünf Minuten oder so, wie lange das dauert.
MP40, Rapid Fire geht ab.
Ja, dazu muss ich erst mal Plustigen.
Hast du alles auf Low gestellt? Ja.
Ich antworte auf fast alles.
Holistik. Auf fast alles.
Allerdings, wenn die Fragen dumm sind,
kann die Antwort auch dumm sein.
Je nachdem, ne?
Debated, overrated, outdated.
Steam-Statistiken hab ich gestern mal geguckt.
Läuft der Stream jetzt eigentlich ordentlich?
Hatte...
Scott hier hatte
5.000 Spieler.
Mehr als beim Release-Tag.
Also, ich hoffe, das wird sich noch ein bisschen halten.
Dass das wenigstens spielbar bleibt.
Echt.
Der spawnt hinter mir. 100 pro.
Ich sag's euch, der spawnt hinter mir.
Das ist Call of Duty Spawn-System.
Okay, wo sind sie?
NA-Aim.
Geht's ab? Fritz-Bomb.
Oh, Dropshot.
Get dropshotted.
Rapid Fire... Also, die Waffenaufsetzung.
Die machen wirklich sehr viel aus.
Achso, ich kann eine F drücken zum Respawn.
Fritz-Bomb.
Bam.
Ausgefritzbombt.
Komm her, jetzt werden wir Erster. Go, go.
Der spawnt hinter mir.
WAS? Woher wusste er, dass ich da jetzt gleich um die Ecke komme?
Ich hab schon pre-firet da hin.
WTF?
Ah, okay, ne. Der hat auch hingeguckt.
Aber ich spawn wieder direkt hinter ihm.
Seems, seems sehr fair.
Alter, warum?
Warum spawnt man hier so viel mehr Damage?
Komm, Erster, Erster.
Da geht noch was.
Achso, ich sollte vielleicht respawnen, anstatt...
...sinnlos hier rum zu rennen.
Ich hab da hinten Gegner gesehen.
Fritz-Bomb.
Fuck, boah.
Ich hab den nicht gesehen.
Jetzt geht's ab. Was?
Oh, hat der Ghost einen gehabt?
Echt?
Mal hören, mal hören.
Geht doch.
Rekt! Rekt!
3-7, jawoll. Geht doch.
Was? Ich bin auf Gold-Ranking getroppt?
Man hat nen Ranking in dem Game?
Und vor allem, wo sieht man das?
Äh, Speedcaller.
Max, warum spielst du auf...
ähm...
Warum spielst du auf Low?
Weil das sonst nicht richtig läuft, das Game.
Man hat echt nen Ranking?
Wo sieht man das denn?
Oder war das ein Witz?
Ich hab einfach keine Ahnung von dem Game.
Easy war das. Easy.
Max, kannst du mir einen PC zusammenstellen?
Guck mal auf Computerbase.
Jebaited, overrated.
Hast du noch ne 1080Ti?
Ja. So, ich mach mal...
Ich mach mal Discord an, Erx.
Discord.
Äh, für 1000 Euro
meinst du X-Flames hats?
Also für 1000 Euro Hardware?
Oder was ist seine Frage?
Oh, Discord-Update.
Bin gleich da.
Leute.
Es ist soweit.
Game wieder gecrashed.
Also der PC-Pod ist unterste Grütze.
Moin. Hallo?
Hallo? Äh...
Hallo?
Discord tut nicht.
Äh...
Oh, Servus.
Ich hab gerade das Game abgespielt, oder?
So, moin. Geht's jetzt?
Ja. Hallo?
Ah, wunderbar. Irgendwie hat's rumgebackt gerade.
Äh, ja, das Game ist abgekackt.
Das Game kackt. Wie ist denn das bei dir?
Kackt das Game bei dir auch laufend ab?
Gar nicht. Null.
Gar nicht?
Also entweder...
Die 1080Ti ist zu schlecht.
Hast du jetzt den neuen Rechner
und bestimmt einen PC neu aufgesetzt?
Hab ich, aber ich spiel noch auf dem alten Rechner.
Du spielst doch auf dem alten.
Frag mich warum.
Ich war noch zu faul,
das umzustellen.
Ich spiel doch auf dem alten Rechner.
Also ich hab jetzt hier quasi
einen was-weiß-ich-wie-viel-tausend-Euro-PC
stehen und ich spiel nicht auf ihm.
Ja, ich weiß.
War ja richtig nötig, ne?
Dann hast du bestimmt pre-ordern müssen.
Äh, klar.
Du meinst den i7?
Den hab ich sowas von pre-ordert.
Äh, Leute, sagt mal, wie ist die Lautstärke
des Rechners?
Passt das so?
Ist das so okay, oder muss ich ihn lauter machen?
Ich glaube, ich muss den ticken.
Wobei, ich kann den ja mal lauter machen.
Müsste, glaube ich, gehen.
Aber bei einer Sache heißt der Rechner,
die Field of View, die resetet sich jedes Mal.
Und zwar in jedem Modus.
Im Zombie-Modus, in der Kampagne.
Aber der Rest bleibt bestehen.
Ich glaub, du bist ein bisschen...
Kannst du schon mal Gruppen-Invite machen?
Bis ich das jetzt gefunden hab, dauert eh...
ewig.
Warte mal, ich mach jetzt Discord einfach mal
einen Ticken lauter. Sag mir doch mal bitte was.
Test, test, hallo?
Ja, ich glaub, so ist besser.
Äh, Gruppen-Invite...
Ich hab's
gestern noch gefunden da.
Die haben doch das ganze Interface ein bisschen überarbeitet.
Ähm...
Jaja, ich find das... Ah, ich seh's hier oben.
Klick.
Click to join.
In der Beta war das der richtige Scheiße, das Interface.
Aber jetzt ist das richtig gut.
Ja, genau.
Genau, das trifft's, das trifft's eher.
Man kann's benutzen.
Das war's aber auch.
Ich hab das Interface von Destiny 2 gesehen, da bekommst du einen Kotz drauf.
Ähm...
Ich hab's in der Beta gesehen.
Also, wenn's jetzt nicht viel anders ist als in der Beta...
Ey,
ich sag dir, da bist du stundenlang
mit Suchen beschäftigt.
Echt? So schlimm?
Ja, teilweise, da drückst du Tab, um deinen
komischen Navigator aufzumachen.
Dann musst du Tab gedrückt halten, um die Map aufzumachen.
Dann musst du auf der Map
E gedrückt halten, damit du deine
Quests sehen kannst oder sowas.
Ne.
Super.
Ich hab jetzt
Push-to-Talk an, und
ich werd mal ab und zu auf den Chat antworten.
Könnte jetzt ein bisschen
verwirrend werden.
Du kannst aber Games suchen.
Ja, ich bin jetzt mal in der Spielmodus-Krieg hier.
Also, für 1000 Euro
kriegst du
auf jeden Fall einen ordentlichen Rechner.
Locker.
Wie viel Gigahertz hat dein
8700K? Ich hab jetzt
5 Gigahertz.
Wie viel hat dein Rechner gekostet?
Du hast doch auch jetzt ungefähr
sowas in der Richtung. Du hast zwar kein
8700K, du hast glaub ich
7700K oder 6800K.
Ja,
unterm Strich, alles zusammen war ich bei...
Mein Game ist
abgestürzt.
Ja.
Ich kann da auch nix
dafür.
Das ist das einzige Game, das abgestürzt ist.
Es stürzt sonst nichts ab.
So, ich starte mal neu.
Hast du auch nicht diese komischen Windows-Updates drauf, oder hast du die drauf?
Du meinst
den Windows-Game-Modus und sowas?
Nein, das ist alles aus.
Wie sieht's mit den Updates aus, die da ausgekommen sind?
Diese Creator-Scheiße und so?
Hab ich alles drauf.
Echt?
Noch vor Release.
Ich hab's quasi noch von Microsoft
runtergeladen.
Also mit dem Creators-Update konnte ich nicht spielen, ging gar nicht.
Achso.
Du meinst das
Neueste oder das Creators-Update?
Also das Fall-Creators-Update ist ja das Neueste
und das Creators-Update ist ja das davor gewesen.
Also mit welchem konntest du nicht
spielen? Mit dem Neuesten oder mit dem davor?
Das Neueste soll ja auch nicht top sein.
Okay, was hast du jetzt?
Version 1.6.07.
Also das vor diesem ganzen
Creators-Scheiß da.
Echt? Das ist ja 2 Jahre alt dann. Ja.
Gibt's da auch noch
Updates für? Klar.
Naja, so klar ist das nicht. Irgendwann
stellen die das wieder ein. Ja, ich glaub mal nicht.
Also wenn, dann müssen sie vorher ihren
Kram da fixen. Also ich hatte so
Probleme mit den Framedrops und allem.
Also es läuft bei mir alles
wunderbar. Das einzige Problem ist,
musst mich übrigens nochmal entweiten,
das einzige Problem ist einfach
hier das neue Call of Duty, was permanent
mit irgendeinem komischen DirectX-Fehler und
Geschiss crasht. DirectX-Fehler?
Was für ein Treiber ist das? Ja, DirectX-Fehler.
Und sonst was.
Na, das
GeForce-Experience-Zeug, was da automatisch
installiert wird.
Welche Treiber-Version? Weiß ich nicht.
308 irgendwas. Schon wieder abgekackt!
WTF? Was ist das denn?
Ich würd dir mal
vorschlagen, du dehnst, weil du hast bei deinen Grafik-Treibern
was du selber drauf, oder? Nee,
das kann nicht sein.
Ich kann stundenlang irgendwie
Battlefield, Overwatch, sonst was spielen. Das liegt
an Call of Duty. Eindeutig.
Das kann ansonsten nichts liegen.
Vielleicht kommt es auch mit irgendwas nicht klar,
was ich auf dem Rechner installiert habe, aber man muss
ehrlich sagen, zumal ich jetzt ja auch auf dem
zweiten Account spiele, ähm,
zweiten Windows-Account, wo
eigentlich kaum was gestartet wird.
Da, so viel
kann das nicht sein.
So, hoffentlich geht's jetzt.
So, ich bin wieder drin.
Das seh ich dich nicht.
Hast du den Welt schon angenommen? Nee.
Nee, ich
hab gar keinen invite gekackt. Jetzt?
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt. Passt.
Discord. Seit ich Discord habe,
hab ich nur crasht. Aber Leute, ich glaub nicht, dass es
am Discord liegt.
Das wär ja noch behinderter, wenn das am Discord liegt.
Da kannst du ja nicht mal schließen.
Kannst du nicht
schließen, da kannst du nicht labern.
Übertaktet bei der 1000... Was übertaktet bei 1080p?
Äh...
Immer
übertaktet.
Aber das liegt nicht daran, dass es crasht.
Weil der Rechner übertaktet ist. Weil ich spiele
nicht auf dem Rechner, der übertaktet ist gerade.
So. Jetzt geht's los.
Was spielen wir dann? Ach, war.
Ich seh's.
Ja, aber wie gesagt...
Deaktiviere die
Hardware-Beschleunigung von der Discord-UI.
Hast du das gemacht? Äh...
Bei Discord hab ich alles ausgestellt.
Overlay, alles.
Ah.
Falls es jetzt nochmal crasht,
mach ich das.
Weil ich hab Discord-Default-Installation ohne irgendwie
großartige Dinger.
Hast du eine Ahnung, wo man eigentlich diese ganzen
so ausrüstet?
Nee, keine Ahnung, also...
Ich war ja mit diesem Hauptquartier oder was
das da ist, da wo man hier seine Post
und sowas abholt, ey, das hab ich so
weggebombt. Da dachte ich, nee, Alter, ich geh
jetzt erst mal zocken.
Ja, nervt dich das auch?
Ja, wenn's halt so ein bisschen überfüllt ist,
ne? Ich find die Idee gar nicht mal so schlecht,
dass man so interaktiv so rumläuft.
Ach, ich find das...
Ich find das voll unnötig.
So, Leute, ihr müsst jetzt mal sagen, wie die
Lautstärke ist von Game und Eax und mir
und allem zusammen, weil ich hab jetzt hier ein bisschen
rumgestellt, dass es sollte passen.
So.
Operation Griffin.
Und wir sind Defender.
Sind die Maps
alle so super
eng wie die Beta-Map?
Nee, nee, nee.
Hier hast du sogar drei Möglichkeiten
durchzukommen.
Okay.
...
Allein schon, dass Discord
Grafikbeschleunigung braucht. Hallo, das ist ein
Voice-Chat-Programm.
Wozu braucht das ne Grafikbeschleunigung?
...
Oh, ich kann in den Turret.
Jetzt werden sie geschreckt.
Ich sitz mal im Panzer drin.
So.
Guckt mir das Ganze an.
...
Ich fahr mal Panzer.
Du ownst die Leute schon, seh ich grade.
...
Bleib mal am MG hocken.
Was ist los, ey?
...
Ich bleib einfach mal im Panzer sitzen.
Au.
...
Wir ab Sonoaco.
Noise, A度 ...
...
Was?
verstehe ach das gelbe das gelbe ist moment das gelbe ist ich mache danach
push to talk an da kann ich ein bisschen im chat labern und es verwirrt uns nicht
oder genau ist
ich glaube ich bin übrigens voller marsch der welt
panzer
ich stehe ja schon wieder vom tank vor allem nichts ist das neue kopf ja das
neue kopf aber es ist schon mal gut zu hören dass es bei dir wenigstens ordentlich läuft
bei mir ist es so kaputt
eingestellt
ich denke eher das liegt am game weil ich meine es funktioniert alles und dann
pc kackt seltenst ab und andere games kann ich stundenlang spielen
wie viele stationen hat die map ich glaube wenn wir jetzt durchgucken
stoppen ist fertig
ppsh ist so ne geile waffe ok sich in den panzer reinzusetzen ist suboptimal
warte welchen
was du eigentlich bei den sap maschinen ganz schalldämpfer drauf
du hast du hast richtig riesen range drop
in diesem spielmodus macht der schalldämpfer sowieso keinen sinn weil die gegner wissen ja wo du herkommst
ja die wissen wo du herkommst das stimmt schon
wat? wir haben gewonnen
hörst dich an?
an wie ein alter youtuber vielleicht bin ich das auch wen meinst du denn leroy
tio nein ich bin nicht hier aber fast du musst mal die pps ch mit schnellfeuer
ich habe jetzt die pps h mit mit rapidfire und ich überlege gerade was habe ich denn sonst noch
dran externe max externe brauchst du nicht der hat ja schon standardmäßig 35 ja
ok muss danach mal einstellen was meintest du rapidfire und
das eine was hier
thinks ja diese geschosse
check 0 wo man hin muss im prinzip eigentlich campen und die gegner
eigentlich campen und die gegner campen und die gegner
daran hindern wenn dings benzin zu holen oder
krumke eier der friseur gibt es noch ein bisschen range und wie hält man die panzer
auf indem man die leute gilt die nah dran sind ok mehr muss man nicht sagen
ja wenn man auf der watch gespielt hat oder
irgendwelche anderen objective basierten games dabei also der regio als
gemeint ist
weg ist
ich finde es aber sehr gut dass es keine stats geht weil das wird es noch zu richtigen rumgekämpft
ist das da kann man so was auch noch mal sehen und wenn man sich das war schon einfach mal sagen
so machen wir es nichtry
die steuern
es das da kann man so was auch noch nicht so viel bedeutet das hat man mir nicht gesagt
weil das ist ein typisches gerät das ist ein typisches gerät dass man sich so weit zwischen anderen
leute kommt man sich sich nicht um einen anderen people riskiert aber der meister kann sich die
lage ausüben
weil das ist so wie es ist ohne grund warum es dann dann ist so eine lege in der braveband
oder ja das ist in der regierung das ist so wie es ist hier schon mal die gage im
aufbaut. C wird gefahren. Okay, ich flanke jetzt mal bei C rum. Okay, C ist safe. A fährt.
Mein fährt nicht mehr. Jetzt haben wir sie, jetzt haben wir sie. Was soll ich hier machen?
50 Gegner. Max, du meinst doch während der Beta, dass du dir das Game nicht holen wirst.
Das stimmt. Also ausschlaggebender Punkt war, dass das Gameplay mir Spaß gemacht hat
und ich einfach nur gehofft habe, dass die Release-Version ohne so viel Cheater-Kacke
auskommt. Was sie bis jetzt macht. Wir halten die ganz gut, habe ich das Gefühl. Also SMGs
sind hier nur so halbwegs zu gebrauchen auf die Range.
Fuck.
Jawoll. Easy. Spätestens in dem Monat ist das wieder voll von Cheatern überlaufen. Kann
sein. Kann sein, mal gucken. Hast du, Erx, hast du eine der letzten Call of Duty-Teile
gespielt und weißt du, wie es mit Cheatern auf dem PC dort gewesen ist?
Ähm, Ghosts habe ich gespielt, das war voll davon.
Ghosts? Das habe ich nicht gespielt.
Advanced Warfare habe ich acht Stunden gespielt, da habe ich auch viele gesehen.
Okay.
Advanced Warfare hat fünf Minuten überlebt.
Gut. Also, naja, dann ist da wahrscheinlich was dran, wenn hier einer schreibt, in einem
Monat ist es wieder von Cheatern überlaufen. Kann gut sein. So. Da mache ich jetzt mal
diesen Range-Drop-Dings dran.
Kannst aber mit der PPSCH nicht wirklich aus der Hüfte feuern. Das ist zu kurz mit der
Waffe. Gibt es bessere.
Meinst du, ich sehe jetzt zwar nix, was...
Ach, hier. Advanced Rifling. Increased Damage Falloff Range.
Und das mit Rapid Fire. Ja, gut, das könnte, das...
Der Mast hat extrem viel Schaden durch die Wände durch in allem.
Wow. Probier ich mal aus. Wie findest du das Game bis jetzt? Also, Gameplay-Technisch hat es mir in der Beta auch schon Spaß gemacht.
Team Deathmatch ist mega random. Hast du ein bisschen Team Deathmatch gespielt schon?
Nee, gar nicht. Also, in der Beta war das ja echt random.
Das ist total random.
Da dachte ich mir, nee, das muss nicht sein. Also, ich hab's gerne, wenn ich weiß, wo die Frontlinien sind. Ja.
Ja. Vorhin in eine Richtung geguckt, Gegner da, rechts daneben ein Gegner und dahinter ein Gegner. Was willst du da machen? Das war total random. Du kannst, du kannst ja schlecht mit Spiegeln um dich drum rumlaufen, dass du immer so, ne?
Du brauchst einen Monitor neben dir, einen Monitor hinter dir. Es wäre natürlich geil, wenn das Game das unterstützen würde.
Aber das war, das war einfach random, Team Deathmatch. Total random.
Ja, wenn du einen Monitor hinter dir hättest, dann stell dir mal vor, du drehst dich doch die ganze Zeit nur mit dem Stuhl im Kreis.
Ja. Dann hast, dann müsstest du die Tastatur und die Maus an den Stuhl machen, Funk, also Funktastatur, Funk, Maus und dann kannst du dich die ganze Zeit im Kreis drehen und du hast Rundumblick.
Musst dich da, wenn du, wenn du das mal ein, zwei Wochen gemacht hast, wird's dir auch nicht mehr schwindelig.
Mhm.
Ich stell mir das vor allem schön vor.
Ich stell mir das vor allem schön vor, wenn man sich im Stuhl dreht und dann erst mal die Maus noch hinterherziehen muss, den Monitor und so.
Ja deswegen, das muss alles gemountet sein auf dem Stuhl.
Mann, Mann, Mann.
Hast du die Battlefront-Beta gespielt?
Mhm.
Und? Was sagst du?
Grausam.
Grausam? Okay.
Ja, mir hat's auch nicht gef... Mir hat's so wenig Spaß gemacht, dass ich noch nicht mal die Helden wirklich ausprobieren wollte.
Hattest du überhaupt Spaß? Wenn du so wenig Spaß hattest?
Gar nicht. Null.
Ich auch nicht. Es kam keine Freude auf. Ich fand das Gunplay scheiße und die Heldenkarten, die waren auch total langweilig.
Also das hier, diese, diese Drückse, so ein richtiger Buttonsmasher war das. Mit Scare hat das einfach nichts zu tun.
Also, es hat überhaupt keinen Spaß gemacht. Und an der Optik liegt's nicht. Gut aussehen tut's.
Bei mir war die Beta total verwaschen. Also auf 30 Meter kommen wir nichts mehr sehen.
Es ruckelt.
Echt?
Nein, die, die Intro-Sequenz ruckelt. Also, es soll ruckeln.
Jetzt wird's eklig.
Moment, das sind NPCs, oder?
Total, ja. Ja, Raub- und Rauchgranaten und alles.
Was? Oh, fuck. Was ist Tactical Grenade werfen?
Äh. Kein... Ist es nicht G? Okay.
Taktische Granate war E.
Ach, E. Ah. Ah, hier muss man, muss, muss man aufknipsen. Verstehe.
Hast du noch ne Rauchgranate für rechts?
Nö, ich hab gar keine Rauchgranate ausgerüstet.
Was?
Ja, dann mach du mal nen Kugelfang. Ich will durchlaufen.
Ich hab links, ich hab links auch aufgemacht. Links guckt grad keiner.
Okay, dann lass los.
Go, go, go.
Nee, ist nicht doof.
Echt?
Oh, ich hab, ich hab nen Flammenwerfer. Jetzt geht's ab.
Gespawnt, dann wird tot.
Das ist halt richtig mies. Du brauchst ein ganzes Team Rauchgranaten für den ersten Spot.
Ich hab... Oh, fuck. Ich hab, glaub ich, noch nicht mal ne Klasse mit, mit Rauchgranaten.
Aber das werd ich mir gleich danach machen. Ich hab ja bis jetzt noch überhaupt keine Objective-Monie gespielt.
Und in TDM brauchst du halt keine Rauchgranaten.
Ja.
Ich will hier durch, aber es kommt keiner.
Ich bin der Einzige hier vorne.
Ja, ich versuch grad vorzukommen, was nicht so einfach ist.
WTF? Das ist mega eklig.
WTF?
Kann man wenigstens spawnen? Könnt ich jetzt vorne spawnen?
Nee.
Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber ich bin jetzt drinne.
WTF? Man kommt echt nicht vor.
Ich geh mal rechts die Bunker ausfeuchern.
Einer down.
Ach, das war...
Zwei down.
Ich versuch vorzukommen, aber...
Ich bin voll...
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ich versuch vorzukommen.
Ey, spawn tot, spawn tot.
Erx geht ab. Räumt auf.
Okay, ich bin da.
Nee, hier gehts gar nicht lang.
Wie kommt man überhaupt rauf?
Unten durch die Mitte?
Nee.
Äh, Leiter benutzen.
Unterlaufen.
Äh...
So.
Einmal aus der Hüfte schießen mit dem Ding ist wirklich kacke.
Ja, du musst immer noch scopen.
Immer.
Nein!
Oh, oh, oh.
Einer ist links...
Oh, einer links.
Also, der linke Bunker wird ordentlich gecampt.
Einen hab ich drinne.
Hab einen links.
Ich geh mit.
Einen hab ich...
Oh, da sind drei, drei, drei...
Oh, fuck.
Drei Stück drinne.
Drei Stück, ich hab die gerade gehört.
Wo ist der Rest eigentlich?
Weiß ich nicht.
Das sind irgendwie Afghanen.
Hotz.
Wie kommt man hier eigentlich rauf?
Nur durch diese Tür in der Mitte?
Nee, nee.
Es gibt auch Leitern zum Bunkern.
Ich bin drin in A.
Ah, hier gibt's ne...
Ah, hier gibt's ne Leiter.
Verstehe.
Okay, da muss man sich erst mal dran gewöhnen.
Das ist ja voll Call of Duty untypisch.
Es gibt mehrere Wege und die sind sinnvoll.
Okay, ich komm mit dir.
Da sind einfach mal wieder vier Gegner drin.
Aber es sind ganz schön viele Leute von uns.
Nein!
Alles leer geschossen.
Boah!
Ich glaube, dieser Modus ist wirklich cool, wenn man das, sagen wir mal, mit...
Also entweder halt zu zweit spielt und man weiß halt genau schon, wo was geht, oder mit
mehreren Leuten.
Ich glaube, da macht es echt Spaß.
Wir haben ihn fast.
Okay.
Overtime.
Ist ja wie in Overwatch.
Overtime push, best push.
Wie ist deine Meinung zum Spiel?
Ähm, macht Spaß.
PC-Port, zumindest bei mir auf dem Rechner,
naja.
Hält sich in Grenzen.
Ansonsten Gameplay-Technik, macht Spaß.
Team Deathmatch wirkt total random.
Und es wäre halt auch cool, wenn man neue Loadouts machen könnte,
während man spawnt.
Also jetzt am Anfang der Runde ingame, weißt du?
Das hätte was.
Könnte mir jetzt Rauchgranaten ausrüsten.
So, viel Spaß beim Ballern.
Das ist ja fast schon Zombie-Modus.
Ab einem gewissen Punkt ist der AI sogar weg.
High Skill.
Okay.
An B, ich hab den an B.
Weiß nicht, wo er hergekommen ist.
Man sieht halt wirklich nicht,
wie viel durch die Ritzen hier.
Sag, wenn ihr Hilfe an A braucht.
Ich komm rüber.
Ich glaub, hier ist nix mehr.
Au!
Kopf geschleibt.
Äh, Tweezy Pop, keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Irgendwann Just Dance und...
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich bin auf dem Weg.
Jetzt verlieren wir A.
Haben wir A, okay.
Der Bunker ist gefallen.
Verteidige den letzten Bunker.
Was, WTF?
Hol die B-Champ.
Oh, shit.
Sind drinnen in B.
Es gibt ein Auto und ein paar Schienenpistole.
Oh, das ging aber schnell.
Moment, ich check's grad.
Nicht so.
Genau.
Ah, schon wieder drinnen.
Moment, wo geht's hier überhaupt lang?
Ich bin hier irgendwo drinnen, wo ich nicht rauskomme.
Hä?
Hey, kommt oben!
Ich check's wohl, wo's lang geht.
Ich glaube, das könnte echt Spaß machen, wenn man da ein bisschen besser durchblickt und das koordiniert macht.
Ja, ich eins von allen, wie ich sie du schon mal zocken.
Die Efin sollte mal ganz normale Granaten haben.
Ist ja sinnvoll.
Links kommt was rein.
Harambe ist bei uns im Team.
Das ist ja fast wie in Overwatch.
Harambe never forget.
Geht's hier oben lang?
Da ist er schon wieder drin, ey.
Oh, oh, oh.
Von hinten irgendwo.
Ich weiß nicht, von wo.
Oh, fuck.
Läuft aber ganz gut.
Ich glaube, der Modus ist der beste
zum Waffenattachments und sowas freispielen.
Du machst hier so viele Kills.
Ja, aber gerade wenn du mit Objektiv und sowas machst,
das ist halt...
Team-Destmatch dauert ewig,
bis du da was freigelevelt hast.
Hier machst du zwei, drei Runden,
Waffe frei.
So ist das nice.
Ach, du bist das.
Was denn?
Ich hab grad auf dich geschossen.
Ja, manchmal sieht man nix.
Manchmal verschwinden so die Namenstecks.
Uh, da ist noch einer drin in der Mitte.
Wenn man das mit einem Teamspiel
und die Headclitch-Position kennt,
ist hier Game Over für die Attacker.
Hast du richtig gewonnen.
Oh, nee.
Fuck.
Wie hat dieses Objektiv jetzt funktioniert?
War das auch nur drinnen stehen?
Nee, die mussten hier die Kästen kaputt schießen.
Ah, ach so.
Verstehe.
Ja, und den einen hab ich einmal verfehlt,
deswegen haben wir jetzt gerade verloren.
Weil ich einen Schuss verfehlt hab, so.
Ja, ich bin auch genau zum gleichen.
Moment, also, Sekunde oder so vorher verreckt.
Das war...
Weißt du, Overtime-Push.
Kennst du das doch noch?
Geschneibert.
Ah, ist das nicht.
Ich komm rüber.
Ich hab immer viel Leben.
Äh.
Wartebällchen.
Manchmal hast du das Gefühl,
mit SMG zu verschießen, Wartebällchen.
Hitmark, Hitmark.
Hitmark, auf, passiert nix.
Manchmal bin ich nicht so ganz sicher,
ob das, äh, da, wo die Hitmark ist,
ob das überhaupt dedicated ist oder was.
Gestern lief das fabelhaft
und heute ist das irgendwie so,
weiß nicht.
Man hat ja überhaupt gar keine Ping-Anzeige.
Deckt.
Richtig.
Ist das, ist das Rush für Arme?
Quasi.
Quasi sowas in der Richtung.
Aber nicht nur M-Comps.
Was hältst du von,
von Infanterie-Kit
mit, äh, drei bis vier Attachments
an so einer Primärwaffe?
Taugt das?
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Wenn es eine Waffe gibt, die darf ich nicht aufnehmen.
Ah, man könnte irgendwie so die SDG spielen.
Mit Rapid Fire und Scope und Griff und allem.
Oh, die sind an B.
Kriegt ihr das, äh...
Ich bin dran, ich weiß...
Ah, B.
Okay, ich versuch zu defusen.
Ja, passt.
Moment, wo geht's hier lang?
Ne, hier geht's nicht lang.
Ich bin down.
Da sind ganz schön viele an B dran.
Müsste clear sein.
Jetzt ist wieder einer an B.
Ist tot.
Das ist der Schneiber-Typ, geht ab.
Ja, die spielen alle SDG mit drei Attachments.
Scheint nicht schlecht zu sein.
Aber der Bereich, wo man sich bewegen kann hier,
ist schon sehr klein.
B kommt.
Ja, ich komm rüber.
Ich versuch zu defusen.
Ich bin fast dran.
Fuck, da ist noch einer drin.
Ich bin down.
Da ist noch einer noch an B drin.
Aufsätze sind hier sehr stark, okay.
Primed ist bestes Perk.
Was macht primed denn?
Äh, Dame TV.
10 Seconds left.
Wirst du defusen können bei B?
Ich versuch reinzugehen.
Oh, man.
Ich bin tot.
Aber ich glaub wir haben's, oder?
Haben wir's?
Doch, wir haben's defuset.
Oh.
Play of the Game, eindeutig.
Das war Play of the Game.
Junge.
Ach, mit diesem...
Ach, es gibt nen Perk.
Es gibt nen Perk, wo man drei Aufsätze drauf machen kann.
Aha.
Das heißt, als Infantry kann man dann vier Aufsätze auf ne Waffe sind?
Das wär natürlich...
Na gut.
So viele gute Aufsätze gibt's gar nicht.
Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall dick XP.
Verbindung zum Haus.
Unable to connect.
Du auch?
Gut.
Naja.
Taten wir das nicht.
Nur ich.
Ich frag mich, wie das entschieden wird, ob ein Spiel peer-to-peer läuft oder dedicated Server.
Also ich würd sagen...
Also eben hat sich angefühlt wie peer-to-peer.
War total scheiße.
Also warum die in dem Modus noch nicht mal diese komischen Ping-Balken drin haben, verstehe ich nicht.
Da ist siehst ja gar nix.
Ping-Balken ist eh nur einfach, weil man was verstecken will.
Warum macht man sonst Ping-Balken?
Ich bin gerade rausgeflogen.
Ich gehe mal kurz auf K2-Minuten. Bis gleich.
Ja, bis gleich.
Also drei Attachments kann ich mir gut vorstellen, Leute, dass das abgeht.
Aber vier, ich gucke mir das jetzt gerade mal an, bis der E-Ax wieder da ist, was man da attachen könnte.
Also gucken wir uns jetzt mal zum Beispiel hier StG-44 an.
Da könnte man Advanced Rifling auf jeden Fall, Rapid Fire auf jeden Fall.
Na gut, das ist schon geil.
Ich meine, guck mal, da könnte man Advanced Rifling, Rapid Fire, Extended Mag und einen Griff, der den Recoil reduziert.
Irgendwie sowas könnte man als vier Aufsätze dran machen.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich schon ziemlich geil.
Ja, ja, ja, glaube auch. Ich glaube auch, das wäre richtig geil.
So, dann gucken wir mal hier bei der Püppisch, was man da drauf machen könnte.
Da könntest du drauf machen.
Ja, guck mal, ich könnte beispielsweise mit drei Attachments, würde ich sagen, Rapid Fire, Advanced Rifling, Extended Mag.
Ich glaube, das wäre richtig gut.
So, und wenn man dann Infantry spielt, dann Infantry, dann bekommt man sogar noch ein zusätzliches Attachment.
Das klingt ziemlich gut.
Und wenn es das Perk, dann mit...
32 gibt es, das habe ich ja bald.
Hä?
Ich kann das anlocken?
Kann ich das anlocken?
Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich das anlocke?
Habe ich es dann jetzt gleich?
Oder kann ich das wirklich erst mit Level 32 ausrüsten?
Weil ich meine, warum kommt denn hier überhaupt das Unlock?
Warum kommt denn hier überhaupt das Unlock-Symbol, wenn ich noch gar nicht das Level habe?
Ach, Prestige-Token, dann habe ich es für immer.
Lohnt sich das für sowas?
Ich meine, wenn das eh mit Abstand das Beste wäre.
Perk ist, dann möchte man das wahrscheinlich immer haben, ne?
Wohnt sich das?
Ich probiere das jetzt aus.
Scheiß drauf.
Ach ja, hier oben, ich sehe es, ja.
Ich mache das jetzt einfach mal drauf geschissen.
So, Primed.
Jetzt kann man hier...
Ja, das ist nice.
Guck mal hier.
Rapid Fire Advanced Rifling Extended Mag.
Boah, das ist sehr, sehr nice.
So, und weil ich Airborne ausgerüstet habe,
habe ich auch noch länger Sprinten, schneller Sprinten und schneller Klettern.
Das klingt gut.
Nee, nee.
Hier mit 32 gibt es den Perk, wo du drei Aufsätze ausrüsten kannst.
Ich glaube, das ist übertrieben OP.
Du kannst bei der PPSH Rapid Fire Advanced Rifling und Extended Mags nehmen.
Ja, Extended Mag brauchen wir ja nicht.
Meinst du?
Da hast du ja eh schon 35 Schuss.
Ja, aber trotzdem, da kannst du länger ballern.
Na, oder?
Oder, du bringst mich gerade auf eine Idee.
Oder man nimmt anstatt Extended Mag, ähm, denkst hier, Grip.
Von manchen Geschoss.
Ja, oder der Grip.
Du meinst Damage durch Wände.
Ich glaube, mit Griff ist das auch geil.
Rapid Fire Advanced Rifling und Griff.
Das ist bei dem Typ 100 noch hoch.
Das ist ja auf Englisch, ne?
Ich hab's, ich hab's auf Englisch, ja.
So, bist du in der Gruppe?
Kann ich eins suchen?
Ja.
Oder man nimmt Steady Aim.
Dann trifft man aus der Hüfte auch mal was.
Hast du denn in der Hüfte auch keine Atmungsgerüste?
Ach, ne, ne, ne, hab ich schon.
Moment.
Ah.
Brech mal ab, ähm, Smoke.
Ja, hab.
Habe.
Okay, dann, ready?
Ja.
Was?
Bist du...
Unable to connect.
Fuck.
Haha.
So, so viel zum Thema, ähm...
Server, ne?
Ja, ich hoffe mal nicht, dass da irgendwelche Spastis schon rumlaufen mit Lobbyhack und sowas.
Mich würde das nicht wundern.
Ich habe ja ehrlich gesagt gehofft, ne?
Man, man kann jetzt einfach mal 1, 2, 3 Wochen ordentlich spielen.
Und quasi, wenn man das Gefühl hat, die Luft ist raus aus dem Game, dann fangen die ganzen Hacker an und so.
Und man denkt sich, okay, ist gut.
Weißt du, aber wenigstens 2, 3 Wochen ordentlich spielen wäre doch schon nicht verkehrt.
Und es ist ganz wichtig, dass das Game...
Das Game in einem Popup anzeigt, dass du die Lobby geentert bist.
Ist ganz wichtig.
Could not migrate host.
Ist es bei dir auch abgekackt?
Weiter ist zur Spielsitzung nicht möglich.
Hahaha.
Das ist so kaputt.
Dedicated servers on all platforms.
Da haben sie uns richtig debated.
Jetzt bist du in meiner Lobby gar nicht drin, oder was?
Äh...
Ich bin schon wieder nicht...
Ne, ne, ich bin wieder rausgeflogen.
Ey, what the fuck?
Heute...
Wo ich heute Morgen...
Wo ich heute Morgen noch gezockt habe, so...
... äh...
... multiplayer und so, das lief stubenrein.
Kein Problem.
Nix.
Ich dachte schon echt geil, ehrlich mein Gott, was funktioniert.
Hm.
Und jetzt...
... äh...
Also, bei dir ist es ja nur ingame, die Connection-Geschichte.
Bei mir kackt das Game ja alle halbe Stunde mal ab.
Ähm...
... äh...
Leider ist der PC-Port und netz-werk-technisch ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Kannst du mich nochmal inviten?
Bist du jetzt getrennt?
Ne.
Hast du...
Ah, jetzt, Moment.
So.
Passt.
Ist...
... ist...
... ist... joint.
Sofa extrem scheiße.
Ja, das stimmt, Leute.
Das ist wirklich so.
Weiß nicht, was die da machen?
Hallo, ich meine...
Es ist ja wirklich kein Hexenwerk.
Andere Spiele kriegen das auch hin.
Hey, wenn man...
... wenn man...
... wenn man... ... wenn man...
Das, ähm, Unable to Connect to House.
Wieso? Wir konnten doch eben auch spielen.
Das muss gehen. Wir konnten eben auch spielen.
Soll ich dich mal einladen?
Ja, es darf noch nichts.
Aber eins kann man Overwatch nicht nachsagen, dass das Netzwerktechnik nicht funktionieren würde.
Also das klappt.
Das hat zwar auch so hin und da mal wieder kleine Probleme, aber das ist nix im Vergleich zu dem hier.
Das funktioniert echt wunderbar.
Okay.
Ich muss erst wieder Multiplayer connecten.
Okay, wie invite ich überhaupt? Social?
Ja, Social. Friends.
Friends. Ja, da ist er.
Äh, invite.
Okay, du müsstest was gekriegt haben.
Ja, ne? Hast was.
Okay, jetzt such ich mal.
Ähm, Public Match.
Standard. War.
Vielleicht geht's jetzt ja.
Ja, den Stream setze ich...
Ähm, naja, heute nicht.
Aber vielleicht... Unable to play.
Was ist das denn? Sind die Server gerade im Arsch oder was?
Ich bin neu starten.
Vielleicht ist der nicht gekommen oder so. Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, ja, ich starte auch mal neu.
Man weiß ja nie.
Auf der Server-Status-Seite steht, haben sie versucht, ihren Router neu zu starten.
Ist das der Telekom-Support oder was? Das schreiben die auch immer.
Haben sie versucht, ihren Router neu zu starten.
Ist klar.
Ja.
Hallo, darf ich das Spiel jetzt starten?
Wie ist der Zombie-Modus? Keine Ahnung, noch nicht ausprobiert.
Du hast ihn schon ausprobiert, ne?
Ja, eine Stunde. Mit so einem übelsten Freak.
Und?
Also mit einem, der übelst abging?
Ja, ja.
Welle 24 oder 25 ist immer gekommen. Ich dachte, das Spiel hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Dann wollte ich aus dem Spiel rausgehen, weil mir das einfach schon viel zu lange ging auf dieser einen selben Map, ne?
So, da steht ja dran, ja, verlierst alle XP und so. Wenn du das machst, dann ist das scheiße.
Oh nein, nochmal.
Ja, da hab ich mir überlegt, was machen wir?
Ich dachte, wir können hier nicht mehr sterben.
Hast du getrowt?
Ja, natürlich. Ich wollte da raus.
Ei, ei, ei, ei.
Throw von Daffran.
Wobei, die Amis sagen immer, dafran.
So, jetzt, ähm, invite ich dich nochmal.
Social Brandstag invite.
Okay.
Schauen, ob das... Du bist drinne, ne?
Okay, jetzt aber.
Go game.
Lass uns spielen, bis das Spiel unspielbar ist. Wollen wir wenigstens das Spiel ein bisschen spielen.
Wieso bist du denn eigentlich schon Level 24? Hast du da so viel gesuchtet?
Nee, gar nicht. Ich hab gestern nur Unable to Connect. Ich hab gestern nicht gespielt. Ich hab halt, ähm, irgendwie vier Stunden oder so gespielt, ähm, ähm,
halt als es rausgekommen ist.
Gestern nicht.
Das...
Übrigens, Game ist wieder abgekackt, ne?
Ja, ja, aber echt komplett.
Nee.
Aber halt, joinen geht nicht.
Du meinst, wir austeilen? Ja, ich mach mal Solo und guck mal, ob das so funktioniert.
Ja.
Ja, ohne Probleme.
Geht?
Ja.
Hä?
Also liegt das irgendwie an uns?
Fuck.
Ja, aber wir konnten doch eben auch spielen.
Ja, das muss ja nix heißen. Bist du mit... Was ist das für ein Unity Media Modem hast du?
Ich spiel gerade mit Telekom drinnen.
Echt?
Ja.
Okay.
Hm.
Ja, aber das kann nicht sein, dass das mal geht und mal nicht. Also, wenn... Sobald es geht, sollte es eigentlich irgendwie gehen.
Ja, aber das kann nicht sein, dass das mal geht und mal nicht... Also, wenn... Sobald es geht, sollte es eigentlich irgendwie gehen.
Welchen Telekom-Router hast du?
Ich hab ne... Ich hab mir ne Fritzbox gekauft.
Das liegt nicht daran. Das kann nicht daran liegen. Ich mein...
Ey, sag das nicht mit Internet, da hab ich schon Sachen erlebt. Das ist lieber teuerlich.
Ey, der Router kann doch nicht sagen, oh, guck mal, das sind Call of Duty-Packages, die werf ich jetzt weg.
Das weiß er doch gar nicht.
Gut, dann...
Dann spiel ich jetzt mal noch ne Runde Free For All.
Und danach probieren wir es nochmal.
Meld mal Zeit gleich an, vielleicht funktioniert es.
Free For All? Ja, ich hab grad... Ich such grad.
Unable to connect to host.
Ich konnte doch die ganze Zeit spielen.
Du auch?
Liegt an den Server...
Ah, das haben noch mehr Leute, schreiben sie gerade im Chat.
Anscheinend ist das bei vielen so gerade.
Ja, die Server kommen halt von Aldi-Süd...
Meinst du, das ist so qualitativ hochwertig, dass es schon von Aldi-Süd kommt?
Ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht das ist...
Das sind irgendwelche Server aus Bangladesch in Kinderarbeit zusammengesteckt.
Was weiß ich .
In der Wüste.
Free For All
Ja...
Ich schreib Unable to connect to host.
Die schreiben auch welche in chat, dass die gerade in der Gruppe sind und es geht nicht.
Sie schreiben auch welche in chat, dass die gerade in der Gruppe sind und es geht nicht.
Und jetzt...
Ja, das ist ja scheiße jetzt.
Das ist richtig kacke, ja.
So, kann ich denn...
Kann ich denn Lootboxen aufmachen?
Das geht natürlich, ne?
Die Headquarter-Server, die sind natürlich da.
Es wäre ja auch bitter, wenn die Leute
sich keine Lootboxen kaufen könnten, ne?
Das muss getrennt, isoliert
von jedem anderen Netzwerk sein.
Ja.
Die sind wahrscheinlich bei Activision
im Hochsicherheitsrechenzentrum oder so.
Aber artig.
Weil das bringt ja Kohle.
Boah, ist hier voll.
Eine Rare-Lootbox.
Aber geruckelt hat es jetzt gerade nicht mehr bei dir, oder?
Ne, ne.
Ob ich es sehen kann, bist du hier?
Magst?
Leute, weiß jemand, wie ich diesen Krempel ausrüste?
Diese ganzen Skins und so,
die ich da unlockt habe.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ah, hier. Faces.
Ey, du kannst hier alle vier Stunden
bei der Post Gehalt abholen.
Das ist ja fast schon
botting-freundlich, ja.
Musst ja gleich mal einen Bot entwerfen, der das hier abholt.
Da stellst du, ja,
lockst du einfach ein.
Lockst du einfach ein
und machst hier irgendein Auto-Inscript.
Der Beta-Helm.
Ohne Helm.
Das funktioniert hier alles.
Oh, hier hatte ich doch irgendeine animierte Karte.
Dass man hier sogar noch Quests hat und sowas, das stimmt halt nicht.
So, geht dein Game eigentlich wieder jetzt?
Oder bist du auch auf diesem Headquarter?
Ich bin auf dem Headquarter.
Hier sind irgendwelche Quests schon los.
So, ich suche jetzt nochmal Free4All.
Die Firma von Playsender ist outdated.
Das ist normal, ist bei uns auch immer so.
Cheat. Das ist normal.
Das muss so sein.
Milchmann, genauso sehe ich das auch.
Genießen, solange es spielbar ist.
Oh, oh, es geht.
Ein Game.
Ja.
Auf Aachen, mit nur drei Leuten.
Das heißt, es haben viele Leute Probleme, sonst wären es nicht nur drei.
Ein-Euro-Shop-Server sind das.
Kick.
Kick-Server.
Das ist so das unterste, was es gibt.
Guck mal, du kannst ja probieren, ob du joinen kannst.
Also, ob du in einem Game joinen kannst.
Sobald du joinen kannst,
können wir nochmal Games suchen.
Oh, nice.
Ich gucke jetzt erst mal Free4All, ob das Game...
Okay.
...sempelfrei läuft.
Du hast ja eine Runde Teamdefmatch.
Schein zu gehen.
Mach das mal.
Ich muss ja Free4All mal schleichen.
Oh, gesniped.
Schein so.
Sollen wir gehen?
Ich kann spielen.
Ich kann auch rausgehen.
Hast du Bock, schnell eine Runde Teamdefmatch zu spielen?
Können wir machen, ja.
Ich liebe, kannst mich entweiten.
Holst du dir eigentlich wieder ne neue Katze?
Ja, hab ich vor!
vor vorher will ich noch mal bisschen unser unser hof tor absichern dass sie
nicht direkt auf die straße rennen kann der alte katze war das total egal die
kam der ersten seh nicht mehr hoch und zweitens wusste die das dann eine
gefährliche straße ist aber die neue weiß das nicht und die muss ja nicht
direkt auf die straße rennen weil ich will das hof zuerst noch ein bisschen
absichern und den zaun oben am richtung garten noch so ein bisschen nach vorne
was dran machen das nicht drüber kann also spricht die kann dann die hat den
kompletten hof anhebelte connector aus man kann ich mir vorstellen die wollen
so viel geld einnehmen dass das ist aber selbst mit mit hamster strom versorgt
werden haben sie die callcenter mitarbeiter müssen quasi während sie
nicht telefonieren treten weil das kann doch nicht sein dass du
den konzern der mitarbeiter die anwesenheit bezahlt deswegen muss der
strom erzeugen für die server
hallo lumpen meckes bitte funktioniert ja please game plus rng und und und ich
bin alleine angeblich und level 1 steht da ich habe so das gefühl das funktioniert
nichts
also jetzt macht es gar nichts gerade
jetzt bist du wieder da
wort
jetzt bist du wieder weg
oh meine fresse warum ist das spiel so kaputt
warum ist das spiel so kaputt das kann es doch nicht sein
so weißt du was ich in walde jetzt noch mal und wenn es da nicht geht dann
spielt halt irgendwie noch ein paar runden so aber das ist kacke ich wollte eigentlich nur einen modus ausprobieren
social trends
ja das ist kacke ich wollte eigentlich nur einen modus ausprobieren social trends
der mcore spiel
schickst du nochmal in den wald
kann man
kann man leute irgendwie anschreiben
hast du gekriegt
ja
ah du bist schon drin ok
ok leute hoffentlich gehts jetzt
ich such jetzt mal ne runde team deathmatch
einfach in einem spielmodus wo garantiert genug server und genug spieler da sind
ich hab doch die ganze zeit schon team deathmatch gesucht
oh leute
ok
ich krieg die krise ich brauch meinen boxsack wo ist er
wo ist er hier
kack game
ja ich spiel mal ne free for all runde
lass mal zusammen queuen vielleicht geht das
ok warte mal
bist du ready
ja ich spiel mit der maus drüber
3 2 1 go
nope
Moment, es lädt noch
One potential game found
Unable to
Alter, ich krieg die Krise
Das Game macht mich fertig
Warum ist das so schlecht?
Und die Leute im Chat schreiben auch
Sie haben ähnliche Probleme
Ja, das ist jetzt scheiße
Totale Scheiße
Tja
Ich spamme jetzt einfach
Suchen
Und man kann doch nicht mal suchen
Spammen, weil es erstmal 10 Sekunden laden muss
Nachdem man rausgeflogen ist
Ja, ich glaub das Game ist gerade richtig
Rip
Das ist Rip, ja
Okay, es ist
Sonntagabend, aber trotzdem
Ich guck jetzt mal
Stats
Steam
Steam Stats, gucken wie viele Leute
Das gerade spielen
47.000
Das ist weniger als gestern
Ah übrigens, Game ist
Abgestürzt, lol
Perfekt
Tja
Tja, Stream, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Max, wie findest du das neue Cod?
Ähm
Aktuell
Find ich das neue Cod extrem beschissen
Weil ich es nicht spielen kann
Ich glaub ich spiel gleich Kampagne
Wobei, pass auf
Unable to join Surfer, dann kommt's bei der Kampagne
Äh
Bestens find ich den Maus
Den Maus-Input-Lag im Ladebildschirm
Ich kann jetzt noch nicht mal
Den Multiplayer connecten gerade
Geht gar nix
Doch, jetzt
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr, Leute
Ich hab echt keinen Bock mehr auf den Kack
Sollen wir mal hier
Zombie-Modus probieren?
Ja, können wir mal machen
Ja, lass mal
Lass mal Zombie probieren, falls das überhaupt
Funktioniert
Ja, nach dem N hast du aber schnell
Abgehackt, ne?
Ja, lass mal Zombies probieren
Achso, ein Nazi-Zombie
Doch
Na ja, Quatsch
Was Call of Duty Multiplayer is attempting to launch optional parameters
Äh, okay
Ja, das ist irgendwie komisch
Das kommt immer einmal
Ich weiß nicht warum
Das ist irgendwie so ein Steam-Sicherheitsding
Wahrscheinlich
Ach, du musst noch den Prolog machen, ne?
Bevor da was geht
Ich hab noch
Wie lange geht das?
Zwei Minuten
Ne, dann klicke ich lieber
Mein Game hängt übrigens wieder
Ne, jetzt geht's
Multiplayer
Achso
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob man den Prolog abbrechen kann
Ich guck mal
Das Laden dauert hier aber auch schon wieder so lang
Ich spamme jetzt, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen
Free-for-all
Im Matchfinder
Welcome
Ah, ne, ich kann den skippen, den Prolog
Soll ich dich mal einladen?
Äh, ja, mach mal
Ich hab halt null Ahnung, ne?
Ja, ich hab gestern so viel auch nicht gemacht
Was wusstest du?
Ähm
Ich muss auf euch das öffentliche Spiel drücken
The Final Rike
Rike
Select Character
Können die
Unterschiedliche Sachen
Ich hab ja nicht so viel umgemacht
Es war mir alles zu blöd
Das alles durchzulesen, was die machen
Da ist alles Geld
Fancy, Medic, Medic?
Okay, Medic ist bestimmt nicht schlecht
Spielen wir mal Medic
Okay, es lädt, es lädt
Es scheint zu funktionieren
Loading, Loading
Es lädt aber verdammt lange, ne?
Aber solange es lädt
Ist es noch nicht abgestürzt
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt
Kennst du den Typ noch?
Wenn es lädt, dann
Was macht's, wenn es lädt?
Dann stürzt es ab?
Oh, es macht Geräusche
Ich hör Wind im Hintergrund
Ja, Ladescreen zu Ende
Und neuer Ladescreen fängt an
Error
Geil
Oh, nee
So, ich geh jetzt wieder in normalen Multiplayer
Und spam jetzt einfach noch ein paar mal Free For All
Das ist mir grad zu dumm
Was willst du machen, ja?
Das liegt nicht an uns
Leute im Chat haben auch Probleme
Dann geh ich vielleicht Destiny 2 wieder zu
Oh Mann
Wenn das nicht geht
Wir spielen einfach morgen noch ein paar Runden
Ich bin ja morgen eh noch
Nicht auf der Arbeit
Also Montag halt, ne?
Das passt
Dann mach ich mal Discord aus
Bis morgen
Tschüss
Ich weiß nicht
Ob jetzt noch eins, zwei Games
Ordentliche Games funktionieren
Aber das Connecten zu Online Services funktioniert schon mal gar nicht
Ich hab's sowohl mit Telekom Leitung
Als auch mit
Unity Media Leitung
Zwischenzeitlich schon ausprobiert
Und keine Chance
Der Ajax hat ja auch Unity Media
Und bei dem ging's ja auch nicht
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an hier
Was ist das hier?
Wollen die mich verarschen oder was?
Nee, wollen sie nicht, die können's aber nicht besser
Montags keine Arbeit.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Er hat entschieden, was möchtest du mir damit sagen?
So, free for all.
Komm, let's game.
Bless RNG.
Give energy.
Max, was hat Activision falsch gemacht?
Zu wenig Server zum Release.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne ja die Architektur dahinter nicht.
Unable to connect hosts.
Jawoll!
Drecksteile.
So, probieren wir das Ganze nochmal.
Ich meine, zwischenzeitlich ging's ja mal ganz kurz.
Aber nachdem's auch keine Games findet hier oben, ne?
Lächerlich.
So kaputt, ey.
Na, dann würde ich Battlefield 3 sagen.
Oh, oh, oh!
Es hat eine Lobby gefunden!
Der Kampfhahn ist auch am Start.
Und Mercy.
By the way.
Oh, die ersten Leute fliegen schon raus.
Mercy main.
Auf der Xbox funztest du.
Na gut, das hat ja jetzt wenig zu sagen.
Da stehen die Server wahrscheinlich bei Microsoft.
Und die wissen, wie es geht.
Oh, oh, oh!
Das sieht aus, als würde es funktionieren.
Und...
Hey, hey, hey!
Es lädt!
Unglaublich!
Nach 40 Minuten oder so, haben wir wieder ein Game.
Krasser Scheiße.
Der Sound ist weg.
Hören.
Ich hab in der Mitte was.
Gehört.
Oh, Mann!
Call of Duty tot.
Guckst nach da, kommt von der anderen Seite was.
Spawn.
Ach so, F.
Muss ich mir merken.
Fuck, ich war nur angeschlagen.
Mist.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur reloaden.
Äh, äh.
Denken.
Meine Güte, ey.
Kann ich heute mal wieder was treffen?
Aber nicht.
Grr.
Wartebällchen.
Sag mal, was ist hier los gerade?
Ich will was killen.
Oh, öh.
Oh.
Ich hab gar keine.
Bust kill.
Gucken, von wo hier was kommt.
Wir stelzen uns jetzt hier lang.
Ah, Mann.
Komm.
Stecken wir uns.
Fuck.
Spring.
Du bist, bist voll in der Zange immer.
Was willst du denn machen?
Letzter Schuss.
Ich muss raggen.
Rag.
Ich hör nix.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Du, da.
Immer von allen Seiten und das, obwohl es Free-for-all ist.
Dabei hatten wir davor so ein richtig krasses Free-for-all.
Irgendwie 30-5 oder sowas.
In A-Aim.
Na, ach so.
Was ist das denn hier?
Wie willst du denn hier was machen?
Okay, wieder alte, alte Free-for-all-Tactics rausholen.
Man rennt nirgendwo rein.
Man läuft an der Seite der Map.
Man wartet.
Und hört, was der Gegner macht.
Und wird von hinten gefickt.
So muss das sein.
Oh, ich hab keine Granate ausgerüstet.
Oh, doch.
Ach, ich hab noch meine Kack-Brand-Granate.
Egal, aus welcher Ecke.
Bei dem Teil kann man wieder gut Dropshotten.
Ich weiß nicht, ich find Jummshotten irgendwie besser.
Gibt es leiser Laufen?
Oh, oh.
Da geht's herunter.
Gott.
Was sind das?
Was für Spawns?
Die alte Free-for-all-Taktik.
Schön außen laufen.
Wollen die mich verarschen alle gerade?
Was?
Oh, wo ist der denn jetzt?
Dass ich da bin?
Hallo?
Warte, Bällchen.
Links war noch einer.
Wir holen auf.
Fritzbomb.
Wo kommen sie her?
Was?
Warte, Bällchen.
Nee, ey.
Wie viele soll ich hier noch treffen?
Ah, wir holen auf.
Wir holen auf.
Ja, Eax, das stimmt schon.
Wenn ich treffen würde, wären die auch tot.
Talkst du eigentlich doch Overwatch?
Ähm, ich würde gerne.
Aber der Rank-Modus macht mich fertig.
So, mal gucken.
Was gibt's nochmal bei Infantry?
Ah, das.
Mountain.
Mountain ist die Free-for-all-Klasse.
Silent Movement.
Wobei, Silent Movement, da kann ich keinen Schalldämpfer drauf machen.
Schalldämpfer ist ja anscheinend eine exklusive Sache für Airborne.
Und Schalldämpfer ist im Free-for-all schon immer saugut gewesen.
Oder?
Schalldämpfer?
Nee, Schalldämpfer gibt's sonst nicht.
Nee.
Oh, Spiel läuft.
Spiel läuft.
Wieso genau macht sich der Rank-Modus fertig?
Hab ich ja schon öfters erzählt.
Hauptsächlich nervt mich, dass es keine reine Solo-Queue gibt.
Was diese ganze One-Trick-Kacke noch belohnt wird.
Gibt ein paar Sachen.
Anscheinend läuft's jetzt wieder.
Wobei, das ist die Lobby, die ich hier gefunden hab.
Du kannst ja mal probieren, ob du wieder Games findest.
Hallo?
Suche Gegner.
Ja!
Da kommt er um die Ecke.
Max, ist das Aufrüsten schon abgeschlossen?
Meins PC?
Spiel noch auf dem Alten.
Der Schrei, ey.
Ist der Typ da hinten drin?
Fuck!
Warum ist das scheiß Magazin jetzt leer?
Bisschen leiseres Movement wär nicht verkehrt.
Ich hab übrigens immer noch die Kackgranate ausgerüstet.
Okay, mit ein bisschen Konzentration geht das.
Da kommt was links.
Hinter mir.
Fritz-Ex-Bombing-Mission ready.
Fritz-Bomb.
Oh, wa... den hab ich nicht gehört.
Die Bombe sackt.
Oh Mist, ich wollte da reinfliegen.
Die Bombe sackt für Free-For-All.
Ach man, mein Aim sackt manchmal einfach so richtig Balls.
Ich bin da einfach nicht schnell genug drauf.
Der flankt außen rum.
Nein, macht er nicht.
Was?
Achso, der ist da gespawnt, hä?
Fair.
Das ist auch ein mega fairer Spawn.
So, Camp.
Wo ist der andere?
Der sitzt hier bestimmt noch drinnen.
Ich wusste...
Mann!
Ach, fuck, Alter.
Wieder nicht richtig drauf gewesen.
Aber hier kann man das wenigstens ordentlich üben.
Da hat er sich vercampt.
Mit Claymore.
Oh, der Typ, ey.
Der fuckt mich so ab.
Wir sind fast...
Wir haben...
Wir haben ihn fast eingeholt.
Aim!
Manchmal verkacke ich so richtig, ey.
Manchmal treffe ich einfach auf...
Also, ich muss treffen, aber ich treffe nicht.
Echt?
Man hat die Claymore gesehen?
Das sind so...
Das sind so One-on-Ones.
Hier darf ich einen schnell verlieren.
Sehr fairer Spawn hinterm Gegner.
Okay, go, go.
Wir werden Erster.
Den holen wir uns.
Fuck!
Mein...
War Q nicht Nahkampf?
Was war denn jetzt nochmal Nahkampf?
Doch Q.
Hä?
Ich verdrückt.
Okay, go, go.
Jetzt volle Pulle raus hier.
Bin nicht mehr rumgecampt.
Mann!
Wie beschissen kann man aimen?
Ich treffe nichts mehr.
Ich muss mal wieder mehr Games spielen.
Äh.
Zweiter ist erster Verlierer.
Nächstes Game.
Aber ich merke schon, das wird wieder.
Das wird wieder.
Hahaha.
Nee.
Ach, wirklich aufregend.
Warst du hierher fallen gelassen?
Ja.
War schon nicht schlecht.
Nee, das ist absolut normales Level noch.
So, also diese komische Fritzbomb ist in Free for All ziemlich kacke.
Scorestreaks.
So, gebt mir mal was ordentliches.
Anstatt der Bombe...
...will ich...
Keine Ahnung.
Nehmen wir den hier.
Aber die Klasse finde ich jetzt echt nicht verkehrt.
Streamst du wieder öfters?
Wenn ja, wie finde ich das heraus?
Facebook, YouTube?
Du klickst hier oben einfach auf Follow.
Und wenn du ganz Hardcore drauf bist, kannst du sogar auf Follow mit E-Mail-Benachrichtigung
klicken.
Dann kriegst du es auf jeden Fall mit.
Aber Follow auf Twitch reicht normalerweise, dass du es in deiner Leiste angezeigt kriegst
hier auf der Seite.
Brandbombe ist geil.
Okay, musst du mal ausprobieren.
So.
Könnte ich erstmal ausprobieren.
Eh die Waffe finde ich für Free-For All schon mal gut.
Öh.
Hallo?
Gegner?
E торinstall nicht ausprobieren, ob du wieder in-Game kommst?
Ah es connectet sich noch was.
Ok wir gehen mal lang.
Da spawnt jetzt einer hinten.
Ich sags euch.
Das war ein A-Aim da muss ich das schneller rüber ziehen.
Da war einer.
Habt ihr den gesehen?
Habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Er stand da.
Habte ich den gesehen.
Aber ich brauche mich einfach umdrehen.
Komm ich.
Ja.
hat gelegen. Äh, nicht gelegen.
Der Kopf hat rausgeguckt.
Ja, probier's nochmal.
Ah, fuck. Ich hab wieder vergessen, die Granate zu ändern.
Erinnert
mich mal, please, dran. Ich muss die Granate ändern.
Weil die ziemlich sackt.
Wir gehen jetzt mal in YOLO-Modus,
was im Team-Deathmatch nicht funktioniert.
Aber hier wahrscheinlich ganz okay ist.
Nicht erwischt.
Was? Ah, fuck. Ein anderer.
Das müssen wir jetzt aber gewinnen.
Jetzt wird gereckt.
Instant-Bam drinnen.
Uh, wo kam der her?
Kack-Aim. Immer noch Kack-Aim.
Ich hör was von links.
Fuck.
Dachte nicht, dass direkt einer da hinten
nochmal spawnt. Was war mit dem los?
Komm her, spawn in der Ecke.
Ja, ich bräuchte auch mal
einen Recon Aircraft. Ah!
Ey, das war voll in die Fresse geschossen.
Aber nope, gibt's nicht.
Sehr fairer Spawn. Der Typ da war noch low
von unserem letzten Engagement.
Ich muss die Granate wechseln.
Psst.
Ich hör nix.
Ist zu laut.
Oh, fuck.
Ich versteck mich jetzt mal hier in der Hoffnung,
er trifft mich nicht.
Ich hab ein bisschen Donation gekriegt gerade.
Ich guck gleich nach dem Free-for-All.
Sag mal, wie viele Bomben kommen da jetzt gerade?
Ich komme hier gar nicht mehr raus.
Fritz-Bomb.
Ich hab da was gesehen.
Das gibt's nicht.
Einmal hab ich ein Aircraft.
Hinter mir.
Der erste geht aber ab.
Das war eine gute Runde.
Was, die Sounds sind leise?
Ne, die Sounds passen doch.
So, ähm.
Kurz gucken, wer da donatet hat.
Hat es zumindest vor allem gehört.
Free-for-All macht mir immer noch am meisten Bock.
Da ist man einfach selbst
für verantwortlich, was man dreht.
Und dann schreibt...
Schaut auf Twitch, Alerts out kommt.
Ja, kommt.
Kommt.
Ist nur relativ leise.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich den mal runtergestellt habe,
aber es hat einen Grund, deswegen stell ich ihn ja nicht mal hoch.
Ich weiß bloß nicht mal, warum.
Eine Runde TDM zusammen?
Ja, wenn du jetzt reinkommst.
Wenn das jetzt funktioniert.
Dann können wir auch eine Runde War spielen.
Oder, ne, lass mal eine Runde TDM zusammen spielen.
Das passt schon.
Invite mich mal bitte, Erx.
Was gibt es denn hier?
Scorestreaks.
Flamethrower.
Soldiers.
Scorestreaks.
Was gibt es denn hier?
Molotov-Counter-Recon-Care-Package.
Firebombing Run.
Okay.
Ist das so was wie Napalm Strike?
Firebombing Run?
Machst du mal wieder Overwatch-Analysen?
Ja, das mache ich, wenn ich wieder Overwatch spiele.
Wenn das Rank-System für mich wieder spielbar ist.
Performance geht.
Manchmal muss man das Game aber neu starten.
Und Netzwerkverbindungen sind auch kacke, Mike.
Also der PC-Port ist so...
Naja.
Scheint zu gehen.
Sehr nice.
Die Firebomb macht Aufschlag, Damage und AOE drumherum.
Sam Fisher, was ist denn die Firebomb?
War das das, was ich gerade aus...
Was ich mir gerade angeguckt habe?
Diesen Level 52 Streak?
Eliminate the enemy team.
Okay.
Gucken wir uns mal an, was man hier für eine gescheite...
Eröffnungsroute...
Laufen kann auf der Map.
Also man kann auf jeden Fall in der Mitte schon mal eine Granate...
Oh man, ich habe wieder die Granate nicht geändert.
Ich bin echt ein Kack-Noob, ey.
Jetzt ab.
Jetzt schreckt.
Von wo kommen sie jetzt?
Ich finde es übelst random.
Kommen sie von links?
Kommen sie von rechts?
Kommen sie von hinten?
Okay, von hinten.
Recon plane.
Wo kommen sie her?
Streckt eure Köpfe raus.
Oh, gibt es nicht.
Die Waffe ist aus der Hüfte.
Echt kacke.
Max, schaust du noch ab und zu zusammen, wie in alten Zeiten?
Ab und zu, ja.
Ab und zu.
Einer der wenigen, die ich noch gucke.
Also die Call of Duty Content machen.
Oh fuck.
Fuck.
Ich dachte mir, da ist ein Teammate, da kann ja nichts schief gehen.
Nope.
Recon auf.
Wir haben Eis im Himmel.
Kommt was?
Hab ich da links was gehört?
Nee, gegenüber habe ich was gehört.
Aber so langsam geht es mir da.
So langsam komme ich da halbwegs rein.
Ich muss noch ein bisschen Free For All spielen.
Da kann man sich einfach viel besser auf das konzentrieren, was man macht.
Okay, da habe ich jetzt nicht richtig geguckt.
Oh, es ist schon 22.11.
WTF?
Warum ist es denn schon, warum ist es denn schon so spät?
Immer von der Seite.
Kommt.
Kopf rausstecken.
Haha.
Ich höre rechts was.
Ach fuck, hier geht es ja gar nicht rechts rum.
Ist nichts mehr.
Gegner.
Da kommt gleich noch was.
Oh, jetzt habe ich gerade noch meinen Killstreak am Start gehabt.
Das war doch mal eine ganz coole Runde.
Ich würde mal sagen, das haben wir gecarried zu zweit gerade.
Zu zweit ist das schon viel weniger random Ergs, ne?
Ja.
selten TdM. Die Granaten,
die Granaten wollte ich ändern.
Okay, gut. Habe ich gemacht.
Und nimm mal die Bar, die soll
gut sein. Ich werde jetzt die
Runde nochmal PPSH spielen, weil
die finde ich ganz gut. Da kann man ein bisschen
Close Border einfach so mal ein bisschen hier
wieder so das Call of Duty
Movement und halt
das ADS
quasi schon und dann auf dem Gegner sein üben.
So, was ist hier ein guter Start? Ich glaube,
ich staue mich in der Mitte rein.
Das ist ganz gut.
Den holen wir.
Sau.
Rekt. Andere Seite ist
einer.
Ich glaube, der ist...
Okay, ich muss mal weg.
Wo ist der hin?
Sag mal.
Kann ich mal was töten?
Zwei Matrix 17.
Nein, hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich wollte flanken. Links oben rum.
Kann man hier hoch? Geht das?
So irgendwie drüber? Nope.
Ich checke nicht schon, wo die Gegner hier spawnen.
Das ist mir komplettes Rätsel.
Wo war spawned, ey?
Komplettes Rätsel.
Mann!
Wieder eine Stellung auf den Kopf gewesen.
Ah, die Streaks kann man im Hauptquartier testen.
Sehr gut.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Hinter uns.
Wotze.
Man checkt null, wo Gegner spawnen.
Wirklich absolut null.
Aber so langsam komme ich wieder rein.
Was?
Oh, da hinten links.
Der hat sich für mich angehört, als wäre er draußen.
So geht das schon mal nicht.
Ah, scheiße geämt.
Aber ich sage euch noch ein paar Tage.
Dann geht es wieder ab.
Der ist oben, ne?
Wie viele Gegner.
Der Eax-Rechze.
Der Eax-Rechze hat...
Das habe ich gerade gesehen im Killfeed.
Zum Beispiel...
Wo sind denn hier Deckungen?
Wo ist hier eine Deckung da?
Okay, von wo kommen die jetzt?
Links.
Den hole ich mir.
Kommt gleich einer.
Da war er.
Ich habe ihn gesehen.
Ich versuche gerade mal den logischsten Weg zu laufen, der gegangen sein könnte.
Da war er.
Geht doch.
So langsam ist es sicher.
Läuft es doch.
Hast du vor, das Game aktiv zu spielen?
Ja, wenn das weiterhin Bock macht.
Und vor allem, wenn die Spieler zeigen, dass es nicht so einfach ist.
Und vor allem, wenn die Spieler sagen, dass sie alle halbwegs im grünen Bereich bleiben auf dem PC.
Und es keine Cheater gibt.
Der Eax-Rechze.
Weggesprayet wären sie.
Wenn es mag spielen, muss das Spiel auch ganz gut sein.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ob man da sich komplett nach meinem Geschmack richten sollte.
Es geht nichts über selbst ausprobieren.
Hat sich das Game verbessert von der Performance zur Beta?
Na ja.
Manchmal hast du nur noch 30 FPS.
Eax-Rechze.
Ich würde sagen, wir verlieren jetzt...
Wir machen jetzt...
Challenge. Wir verlieren kein
Team Deathmatch mehr. Heute.
Wenn wir TDM
verlieren, kann ich off gehen.
Kommt eine meine Meinung zu Super Mario Odyssey?
Oh ja, das würde ich gerne
machen. Dazu müsste ich das Spiel aber weiterspielen.
Also ich hab das
noch nicht. Ich bin noch nicht weit. Ich bin jetzt irgendwie in der
vierten Welt oder so.
Ich spiele es halt relativ lahm.
Guck mir das alles an.
Aber ich hab selten,
vor allem in letzter Zeit, so ideenreiches
Spiel wie Mario Odyssey gesehen.
Next Game.
So, was wollen wir denn als nächstes
anlocken? STG?
Oder wie ist denn
STG? Mal gucken.
STG ist bestimmt nicht verkehrt.
Aber ich hab mich jetzt echt gerade an die
PPSH, an die Pippisch gewöhnt.
Bar soll gut sein, okay.
Bar mach ich mir ne Klasse
danach.
Oh Moment, ist das die Kack... Oh komm,
wir schneibern mal ganz kurz. Wir schneibern noch mal kurz.
Das wird nix. Ich kann's euch jetzt schon
sagen. Ich werd's total
verkacken. Und die Map ist auch
mega scheiße. Die mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Make us proud. Die Map mag ich
überhaupt nicht. Aber wir schneibern
mal ganz kurz am Anfang.
Alter, in A-Aim.
Oh.
Die Bar hast du leider nicht. Och nee, doof.
Die Map ist, das ist die
beschissenste Map.
Also die beschissenste Map, die ich bisher
gespielt hab und die mir in Erinnerung...
Guckt euch das mal an.
Und die mir in Erinnerung geblieben ist als
beschissene Map.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie man sich da ordentlich positioniert,
außer irgendwo zu campen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich hin soll.
Ich hab hinter mir was gehört.
Okay, der ist schon tot.
Also die Map ist
überhaupt nicht an meinem Geschmack.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, wo ich lang muss.
Ey, hallo, ich will auch was killen.
Please.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Sniper-Kacke.
Sieht aus wie bei Estland.
Ja, übelst scheiß Map.
Ich hasse den jetzt schon.
Ich weiß auch null, was ich machen soll.
Geschweige denn, wo ich hingucken muss.
Wo hier Hotspots sind und sonst was.
N.A. Aim.
Ach, man kann keinen Luft anhalten hiermit.
Okay.
Ich bleib jetzt einfach im Fenster stehen.
So.
Die Karte ist übelst gräulicher Rotz.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Wie tief.
Wie spielt man diese Map?
Du magst die Map? Ja, was spielt man denn hier drauf?
Ich sag hier jedes Mal.
Da.
Ansonsten geht es ja mittlerweile ganz gut.
Aber, ey, die Map, ich weiß nicht, wie man die spielen soll.
Jetzt habe ich Schiss zu contesten.
Haha.
Null.
N.A. Aim.
Oh, hinter mir.
Oh, Mann.
Ich treffe manchmal so.
Manche Waffen muss man auch mal ein bisschen langsamer schießen, glaube ich.
Die kannst du nicht einfach nur komplett durchdrücken.
Was ja gut ist.
Ja.
Die spielt man nicht.
Die lieft man.
Ich bin aber im Lobby.
Komm, YOLO, YOLO.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich hin soll.
Ich habe Schiss.
Grafisch sieht es nicht besser aus als COD 4.
Doch sieht es.
Bei mir halt nicht.
Ich habe alles auf Low.
Das Spiel sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Also gar nicht so schlecht für ein COD.
Wie spielt man diese verfickte Kack-Map, ey?
Vote Skip.
Oh, richtig scheiße geaimt.
Das darf mir nicht passieren mehr.
Ja, das...
Da muss ich mich die nächsten paar Tage mal draufhalten.
Mal drauf konzentrieren, dass ich nicht mehr so weit über Aime, dass ich immer merke, wie die Gegner laufen und wie schnell die Gegner laufen und sowas.
Links ist was gespawnt, hä?
Ist hier was drin?
Was macht denn der da?
Ach, das ist diese Kack-Autosniper.
Die suckt.
Der Zombie-Modus ist Bombe.
Okay.
Also, ich habe ihn noch nicht gespielt.
Ich würde ihn aber gerne mal spielen.
Ich habe mir ja vor einer Weile mal ein paar Leute gesucht, die den Zombie-Modus übelst abgehen.
Wollte mal mit denen ein bisschen zusammenarbeiten.
Zusammenspielen, dass die mir das erklären können.
Würde ich gerne machen.
Der Eax carryt uns.
Irgendeiner muss uns ja carryen.
Ich bin's definitiv nett.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Guckt euch mal an, wie ich nett getroffen habe.
Manchmal habe ich aber auch das Gefühl, man geht quasi mit dem Fadenkreuz mitten durch die Gegner durch und trifft trotzdem nicht.
Eax, du musst uns carryen, ne?
Ich bin nicht in der Lage, diese Map irgendwie...
Ich bin froh, wenn ich eine positive Gefühl habe.
Ich bin froh, wenn ich eine gute KD auf der Map habe.
Wisst ihr, an was mich das erinnert?
Diese Panzer-Map in COD 5.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie die hieß.
Es gab in COD 5 so eine Panzer-Map.
Da sind alle auf Panzer gegeiert und sie war spielerisch die beschissenste Map überhaupt in dem Game.
Und da ist auch immer die Zeit abgelaufen.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Carry uns, please.
Mach den Carry-Hook.
Oh, war das knapp.
Das war 45 zu 44, also 75, 73.
11, 11.
Krass.
Die Map hat übelst gesagt.
Ja, so ist es.
Ich finde die Map auch extrem räudig.
Was bedeutet NA-Aim?
Dass es halt NA ist.
Im Gegensatz zu EU-Aim.
Es geht nicht darum, ob wirklich jemand in EA gutes...
Äh, in EA.
Bei EA hat bestimmt...
Da stimmt keiner gutes AIM.
Ähm, es geht doch gar nicht darum, ob wirklich jemand gutes AIM hat.
In NA.
Das ist halt typisches sinnloses Gelaber.
Es ist aber universell, versteht jeder.
Wenn einer sagt NA-Ult, weißt du sofort, was gemeint ist.
Wobei am angesagtesten Overwatch ist immer noch C9.
Egal was ist, ja.
Egal, ob das jetzt auf einer, auf, ähm, Objective war oder nicht, es ist immer C9.
Recoil, Aim down faster und, ja, machen wir halt ein Visier drauf.
So, und Infantry bringt was nochmal?
Ich vergesse das immer.
Rifle und noch ein Primary Attachment.
Okay, spielen wir das mal weiter frei.
Okay, Eax, mach's gut.
Dann spiele ich jetzt nochmal eine Runde Free For All.
So zum Abschluss.
Was ist an Cloud 9 so besonders?
Damit ist nur bedingt Cloud 9 gemeint.
Man schreibt es mittlerweile auch mit Z.
Z9.
Max kriegt nur noch 90 Viewer.
Ich bin begeistert,
dass ich,
wenn ich irgendwie so sinnlose Streams mache,
so irgendwie, ich installiere
auf meinem Server was und so irgendwie
160 Zuschauer habe.
Oh, beste,
beste Free-for-All, ich komme rein, 0,21.
Und jetzt kommt,
kann man die Musik abschalten?
Nice Spawn, nice Spawn.
Das ist aber wirklich Wartebällchen.
Ein Wartebällchen gepaart mit
NA-Aim.
Da muss der immer paranoid sein, ein Free-for-All.
Ich höre was, ich höre was.
Ich muss mal kurz campen.
Ich dachte, da kommt was.
Holen wir uns den mal da hinten rechts.
Kommt keiner.
YOLO.
Oh, was?
Was macht der?
Der Fighter Pilot.
Oh, oh, oh,
muss man den,
muss man den steuern.
Ah.
Ich habe noch Panic Knife probiert.
Ich habe noch das Panic Knife probiert.
Da will er einen Dropshotten.
Psst, ich höre was.
Taktisches Warten.
Kein Campen, bitteschön, ja?
Umlaufen wir ihn,
weil er denkt, ich sitze da immer noch drin.
Und hauen ab.
Wo ist er hin?
Das Free-for-All-Lauf lief aber ganz gut, ne?
Mann, 14,1.
GG.
Eats war das ja schon fast.
Das sind mir die Liebsten.
Die Sniper Quickscoper im Free-for-All.
Ja, WBPD.
So sieht es aus.
Lucio One-Tricks ist das Beste.
Weil ich kann mehr Helden spielen als Lucio.
Aber Lucio spiele ich mit Abstand am liebsten.
Ich kann Zarya gut spielen, ich kann Ana gut spielen.
Ich kann Zenyatta gut spielen.
Ich kann Lucio gut spielen.
Ich kann...
Naja, gut. Reinhard hält sich
recht in Grenzen.
Aber wenn es unbedingt sein muss.
Soldier.
Gut, D.Va kriegt jeder irgendwie gebacken.
Was habe ich denn jetzt freigeschaltet?
Das hatte ich doch schon eben schon alles.
Habe ich hierfür was freigeschaltet?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Max mit Schild im Schiff?
Nein, das war ich nicht.
Das war bloß ein Gameplay.
Das war nicht von mir.
Also ich habe...
Aber dass ich an das Video kann,
muss ich mich natürlich noch erinnern.
So, Map.
Wo geht man jetzt am besten lang?
Ist hier keine Mini-Map?
Moment, kann es sein, dass ich die Map gar nicht kenne?
Oder ist es die Beta-Map?
Ne, das ist die Beta-Map.
Das hast du so gedacht,
dass du mich verarschen kannst.
Den holen wir uns.
Abkürzen.
Oh, NAA.
Nicht richtig ausgerechnet.
Der Typ spawnt hier gleich wieder.
Komm her.
Oben rechts sitzt also einer.
Hallo?
Oh.
Papachef.
Nice Spawn.
Super.
Ich höre da rechts was.
Ich muss auch mal ein Mousepad wieder ordentlich legen.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr wirklich weiter als so drehen.
Das kommt davon, wenn man so wenig spielt,
dann stellt man sich das alles viel zu bequem hin.
Hinter mir war was.
Ich habe eine Donation gekriegt.
Danke, ich gucke gleich nach.
Ich muss mal gucken,
dass ich irgendwo hinkomme.
Jetzt schnappt sich das der andere Typ.
Haha.
Rekt.
Du wusstest.
Du dachtest, ich warte nicht auf dich, ne?
Du hast dich für den Kack-Noob.
Artillerie.
Okay, nachdem die jetzt eh alle in Cover rennen,
mache ich jetzt mal einen Straving Run.
Rekt.
Was denkt der sich denn, der Typ, ey?
Jetzt ist er on fire, der Keks, ey.
22.5, jawoll.
Psst, psst, psst, psst.
Nein!
Oh Mann!
Diese Kack-Camp-Sau, ey.
Claymore ist der ehrenloseste Scheiß aller Zeiten.
Der hat sich gerade wieder irgendwo hingesetzt.
Fairer Spawn.
Äußerst fairer Spawn.
Fuck.
Jawoll!
Nice!
Der alte Sack kann's noch.
Komm, wir machen jetzt den YOLO.
YOLO Run.
Wir müssen nämlich uns beeilen zum Gewinn.
Es ist nämlich 25, 26.
Okay, Reload.
Fuck, der andere ist halt viel zu viel.
Ich muss jetzt hier lang.
Ah, fuck.
Go, go, go.
Spawn, spawn.
Wo kommen sie?
Wo sind sie?
Wir werden die Waffe beenden.
Fuck.
Knapp, knapp.
In die Eier.
Der Nvidia-Container has stopped working.
Ja, ich hatte Fun.
Das Problem ist, ich weiß jetzt nicht.
Wenn ich sage ja, also ich traue ja Activision keinen Meta, ne?
Normalerweise würde ich sagen, hey, ich sag jawoll, ja.
Und wenn ich sage ja, heißt das, ich werde wieder mit ähnlichen Gegnern gematcht.
Was ja gut wäre.
Wobei, ich traue Activision zu, dass...
Quasi, wenn ich ja ankreuze, dass die sagen, nee, das kann ja nicht sein, dass der Max Spaß gehabt hat in dem Match.
Das heißt, wir müssen dem jetzt mal Gegner gegenüberstellen, die viel besser sind, viel mehr Geld für Lootboxen und alles ausgegeben haben.
Dass er sich auch eine Lootbox kauft.
Deswegen skippe ich.
Ich traue denen keinen Meta mehr, ey.
Oh, meine GeForce-Experience ist abgestürzt.
Die GeForce-Experience ist abgestürzt.
Oh mein Gott.
Wie soll ich so nur weiterspielen, ohne GeForce-Experience?
Wie kacke das Game aussieht?
Ja, das sieht kacke aus, weil das Low-Settings sind.
Genau, ja.
Das könnte nicht daran liegen, dass das einfach alles ziemlicher Mist ist.
Nein.
So.
Ähm, wo sind wir?
Hier ist...
Da unten.
Wir gehen jetzt gerade aus.
Da ist garantiert unten einer gespawnt.
Ich wusste es.
Das Free-for-All-Spawn-System ist in jedem Call of Duty schon so unglaublich kacke.
Ich würde es nicht wundern.
Aber wenn hier jetzt einer spawnt, klar.
Ich habe da was gehört.
Ich habe doch da was gehört.
Fairer Spawn.
So fair.
Von hinten kommt was.
Oh, Mann.
Der ist da...
Der muss da gespawnt sein, irgendwo in der Nähe.
Weil sonst hätte ich den auf dem Radar gehabt.
Offer.
Ah, da kannst du nichts machen.
Der kam von hinten.
Der kam richtig hart von hinten.
Ist da reingefahren, ey.
Oh, den habe ich nicht gesehen.
Warum hat der Typ schon elf Kills?
Es geht ab.
Fair.
Ultra fairer Reno.
NA.
So.
Die Spawns.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, so viel kann man das Ding nicht...
...moven.
Wäre auch ziemlich OP.
Ich wusste, dass hinter mir einer spawnt.
Dieses Spawn-System.
Warum verliere ich mit 16,5?
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Ich darf nicht verlieren mit 16,5.
Da ist einer drin.
Glaube ich.
Oh, der hat mich durch den Rauch gesehen.
Okay, der ist tot.
Das heißt, da hinten ist noch einer.
Da.
Scheiße, Mann.
Wir sind vorsichtiger, wenn wir da spielen.
YOLO.
Scheiß auf vorsichtiger.
Mann.
Das muss ich haben, sowas.
Ich höre den.
Ich weiß, dass er daherkommt.
Den muss ich direkt bashen.
Die holen wir uns von der Seite.
Ja, gleich 23.
Ich muss auch erst echt mal auf langsam.
Mega Spawn.
LOL.
Fuck.
Ah, ich war am Nachladen.
Wird es noch gewinnen können?
Warte, Stäbchen.
Äh, warte.
Hä?
Wo?
Was?
Zum?
Wo?
Wo ist der hin?
Hä?
Wo?
Was?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Fuck.
Oh, Call of Duty.
Immer einer von der Seite.
Jawoll.
Gereckt haben wir sie.
Auf den letzten Drücker.
Erster.
Ich habe jetzt...
Ah, ich habe meine Hand geschlagen.
Meine Hand tut weh.
Oh, was ist das sein?
Ah, habe ich vergessen.
GG Eats.
Jetzt wenigstens noch eine Lootbox.
So, wir machen jetzt noch Lootboxen auf.
Morgen auf YouTube.
Für 300 Euro Lootboxen.
Unboxing.
Jetzt würde ich dafür 300 Euro ausgeben, ja.
Kurzes Statement zu den Ergebnissen des Overwatch World Cups.
Ähm, ich hätte gedacht, die USA kommt weiter.
Ich weiß, die USA muss dann gegen Südkorea ran.
Ähm...
Ich habe so insgeheim...
Eigentlich gedacht, es gibt im Finale USA-Schweden.
Ähm...
Ich habe aus folgendem Grund gedacht, dass die USA eine Chance hat gegen Südkorea noch am ehesten.
Weil die wohl richtig harte Scrim-Action gemacht haben, direkt vor World Cup.
Und was...
Wo es anscheinend viele Teams haben ein bisschen schleifen lassen.
Aber Korea einfach too strong.
Ansonsten...
So wirklich wundert, dass...
Südkorea gewonnen hat.
Naja, nee, nicht wirklich.
Ähm, war eigentlich fast zu erwarten.
Auch wenn mein Geheimtipp USA gewesen wäre.
Ähm...
So, kann ich jetzt noch irgendwas abgeben hier?
Wie gingen das überhaupt nochmal?
Orders...
Ich habe noch keine 25 Kills im TDR.
Enter scorestreak training through the tower on the beach.
Okay, da gehen wir mal hin.
Ja, das ist gut.
Wir gucken uns nochmal die Scorestreaks an.
Ähm, ansonsten ist das Ergebnis eigentlich erwartet.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich eher auf Schweden getippt, anstatt Kanada.
Aber wenn man sich mal guckt...
Mal anguckt, dass Kanada auch extrem gute Spieler hatte.
Äh, war das eigentlich auch schon...
War eigentlich zu auszugehen, dass ähm...
Kanada oder...
Oder Schweden.
Und...
Wer auch so ein bisschen mein Geheimtipp war, die ich auch...
Die ich auch gut im Finale hätte sehen können...
Ist...
Australien.
Und zwar nicht, weil es die besten Spieler aus den USA gibt.
Äh, Moment, wo muss ich denn überhaupt hin?
Sondern...
Weil es einfach ein komplettes Team ist.
Und ähm...
Dementsprechend hätte Frankreich auch vorne mit dabei sein können.
Aber die waren in letzter Zeit ja auch schon nicht mehr so gut.
Kann ich hier... Gunstreak?
Ich finde das übelst unübersichtlich.
Was muss ich denn hier machen?
Ich checke das nicht.
Ich bin on the beach. Wo kann ich Scorestreaks treffen?
Wo kann ich Scorestreak treffen?
Wo ist Scorestreak-Training?
General? Bei dem vielleicht.
Kommt man da überhaupt hin?
Tower? Ja wo ist denn der Tower?
Am Turm?
Und umstreamt? Da?
Und umstreamt? Da? Das ist der Turm?
Das ist der mit dem...
Ach da!
Ich will mir also die anderen Killstreaks angucken.
Das ist aber auch bescheuert gemacht, das, kann man das nicht einfach in ein Menü hin machen und gut ist und irgendein Menü, was auf ordentliche Bedienung ausgelegt ist und nicht sowas da, zum Kotzen.
So, das will ich nicht ausprobieren, das will ich nicht ausprobieren, das will ich auch nicht ausprobieren, das auch nicht.
Das sagt, Mörserstrike.
Wie, Moment, man kann die, das sind, weiß das jemand, das da, sind das Perks, die ich ausrübe?
Dass ich ausrüsten kann, dass die Score Streaks günstiger sind?
Ordnance Basic Training, Requisition Basic Training und sowas, sind das Perks?
Okay.
Also das heißt, wenn ich Ordnance Basic Training hab, dann kosten die weniger.
Ist ein Basic Training, Basic Training sind die Perks, oder?
Boah, das ist doch viel besser.
Besser als Artillerie, das ist doch viel nicer als, okay, das ist Napalm Strike, das ist quasi Napalm Strike aus Black Ops.
Carpet Bombay.
Dann würde ich sagen, nehme ich als Streaks das nächste Mal, äh, Aircraft, Aircraft, wo hab ich denn die Artillerie nochmal?
Genau, dann nehme ich Mörserstrike, Fighter Pilot und Recon Aircraft.
Das klingt...
Klingt auch gut, ja.
Das probiere ich jetzt nochmal in Chopper Gunner aus.
Okay, typischer Sinnlos-Killstreak wieder.
Halt der übliche Chopper Gunner Scheiß.
Ich finde solche Killstreaks sind kacke.
Also, ich finde sowas sollte einfach gar nicht in Game Trainer sein.
Egal wie hoch das ist.
Hohe Killstreaks kriegen eh zum sinnlosen Rumcampen an.
Carpet Bombing, okay.
Das ist quasi uns so...
B-B-Dingsbums-2 aus, aus MW2, ha?
Der einfach, der fliegt einmal über die Map.
Oder auch nicht.
Moment, kann ich auswählen, wo der hingeht, oder was?
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Paratroopers.
Okay, Paratroopers sind quasi Hunde, Hunde-Killstreak.
Hahaha, ja.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber du bekommst ja epileptische Anfälle, hahaha.
Das stimmt.
Flak Guns, okay, was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Anti-Aircraft-Battery in Position.
Ready to deny the skies on your Ormets.
Hä?
Was war das?
Ach, das ist ein Anti-Anti-Air.
Ja, das braucht man, glaube ich, eher nicht.
Ich meine, wozu?
So sollte ich das denn ausrüsten?
Ich meine den.
Bei dem kriegst du echt epileptische Anfälle.
Da kriegst du echt Anfälle bei.
Aber ich...
Order Team in position.
Waiting target information.
Order shot out.
Doch, ich glaube, ich werde mal...
Kommt mir nochmal raus.
Ich werde mir nochmal den, den, den, ähm...
Die, äh, äh, na.
Nicht Artillerie.
Dann kann ich Artillerie.
Hier.
Wurzer Strike holen.
Dann habe ich, äh, Recon, Plane, Wurzer und diesen, diesen Pilot Run.
Das klingt doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, oder?
Ich mag das mit ein bisschen niedrigeren Scorestreaks zu spielen.
Diese ultrahohen Dinger ist echt nicht meins.
Hallo, Game.
Laden, please.
Okay, das Game hat keinen Bock mehr zu laden, glaube ich.
Na gut, Leute.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir machen an der Stelle Schluss.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
23 Uhr.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.